[Applause]
all right scum and villainy let's make
some noise
here comes kevin smith and mark
bernardin fat man beyond
[Applause]
hello
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
holy [ __ ] uh we were just in the uh back
alley talking right before the show and
have you seen
this meme that's going around uh last
few days
uh since the batman opened i guess
somebody did the math
on when bruce wayne's parents
would have been killed
i bet it wasn't hard math but they
figured it out and [ __ ] did it take
three hours to do that math i guess
basically
um they were killed in two in our
timeline in 2001.
so there's a meme that's going around
that says you know the waynes were
killed in 2001. that means they were
killed leaving
and then you insert the title of a 2001
movie
and that's what they left [ __ ]
you know and got killed after watching
so i had a movie come out in 2001
and so my friend vincent pereira sent me
the meme and it's like like you know the
the waynes were killed in 2001 leaving a
movie and that movie was
jay inside the bob strike back
and
[Music]
[Applause]
and we were just talking in the alley
about uh me mark nate jc about like the
notion that
if they left jay and sound bob strike
back the family would have been
horrified
having to like how do we explain this
movie to [ __ ] bruce and for like one
golden moment a young bruce wayne was
skipping around going i want to be a
comedy filmmaker
and then
and he's like [ __ ]
snoogins dad snooger
oh good lord um welcome everybody
uh
before we dive into this week's show
just a
shout out uh to a real life [ __ ]
superhero uh captain ukrainian is still
[ __ ] with us man presidents
golinski's just [ __ ]
[Applause]
he's dodging assassination attempts i
saw a [ __ ] article the other day that
like they tried to kill him three times
in two days i'm like that is like three
times more than anyone's ever tried to
kill me ever
um amazing uh the dude continues to
fight and the entire country uh
continues to fight astounding so before
we talk about fake heroes let's just
give it up for a real hero right now man
[Applause]
um okay uh how are you my friend uh i'm
good i'm i
i don't think i'm as good as you are
you've had like 19 announcements dropped
in the press
this week yeah we were a little busy
last week um on friday
there was an article mahalo reporter
about uh how um
i set up a comic imprint of mine own at
darkhorse called secret stash press
named after the comic book store back
east of course
so we're gonna start making comics in
the fall as a
vigilante series called uh masquerade
which i've written with andy mcelfish
who i do edumacation podcasts with
and
drawn by captain rib man who did the
logo for the secret stash does a lot of
our or the artwork that whatever nate
doesn't do captain rib man usually does
um then there's uh a
anthology series called quick stops
which is takes all my characters from
across the view-esque universe
and does
mash-ups so like second issue is yeah
give it up for the boozy guy
second issue is like uh uh randall from
clerks and his cousin brody from mall
rats uh meet at the funeral for cousin
walter the guy who broke his neck trying
to suck his own dick and clerk so
[ __ ] like that where you get to like mix
and match and stuff and that'll have a
bunch of different artists and stuff so
uh once we finish our first year
then we'll move into publishing other
people's comic books hopefully by that
point mark will have something that
he'll want to do really with secret
stash press absolutely part of the
reason that i was like i would love to
do this is i know a [ __ ] ton of writers
with a [ __ ] ton of ideas um or scripts
that went nowhere and it's just like
[ __ ] break them down turn them into a
[ __ ] comic book series man
so you know it's it's i the secret stash
has been selling comic books for 25
years this is our 25th anniversary of
jane salabab secret stash this year
um
so now we're gonna start making comic
books as well so that was the
announcement on friday very cool mike
richardson um who runs and has run dark
horse forever and stuff
um was very
welcoming years ago
1996 we made chasing amy um and i bob
schreck who later went on to uh
co-create oni comics where we did a
bunch of our comic books he was a dark
horse we saw him at a con me and scott
moser and i was like we just did this
movie
set in the world of comic books and and
the guys create a comic book based on
like these characters that were in
clerks mall rats so could we do like a
blunt man and chronic
comic at dark horse and he was like oh
my god yeah man let me ask and then he
called this back and he's like no they
don't want that at all
and so you know then years later uh when
bob schreck started his company he was
like didn't you want to do comic books
and that's how we wound up going over to
oni so it was nice that years [ __ ]
later like one of the first things i
said to mike richardson when we were
talking on the phone i was like did you
know years ago yes i've heard the
[ __ ] story
he's gone but you know it took a long
time to rectify that mistake but here we
are and i was like absolutely so i look
forward to making comic books gonna be
fun as [ __ ] i've been writing for the
last like few months and so i'm all
stocked up like
ready to
to have everything be drawn captain rip
man's on issue two of masquerade i've
got all eight scripts done for that and
eight four scripts done for
for quick stop so like i'm already like
ahead of the schedule i'm very
excited about doing this and then today
we just announced uh the smod castle
film festival back east i've got to
thank you thank you filmmaker um
bag east we've got uh the smod castle uh
podcast theater uh ernie o'donnell who i
run the place with was like let's do a
[ __ ] film festival man he's like you
came from the film festival world let's
help elevate somebody else and i was
fantastic so we announced that today
uh through yahoo and uh and and uh the
submissions like started rolling in
instantly ernie was updating me in real
time he's just like 15 submissions 30
submissions 100 [ __ ] submissions and
[ __ ]
so we'll be going through all those
submissions figuring out which movies
get programmed and then in august we
hold the first uh annual smart cast film
festival back east so don't be surprised
if i'm like i need a judge
i thought he'd be like i need a short
because oh [ __ ]
well don't don't enter and compete and
[ __ ] i don't want to like judge your
[ __ ] like you're doing a secret name
just maybe yeah like premiere it do like
a a backdoor premiere which sounds way
dirtier than i meant it but
but that'd be kind of cool would you do
that would you ever think about doing
that um but i'm now taken with the idea
of entering it submitting it under a
fake name
and then you not programming it and then
me being able to talk about it before an
episode
i mean remember that time you said no
i mean i went to the movie you sunk
money in i would recognize it i've seen
it already but um i think it'd be it'd
be cool maybe we can show it there we'll
talk about that later in any event
yes two big announcements this week i
was part of the news this week news
that's relevant to the interests of the
show so i was very happy about that
indeed what about you what have you been
up to um
i think you know how we often come here
and we talk in in like code words and
very vaguely about [ __ ] they were
working on [ __ ] yeah and uh and people
get frustrated by the fact that
everything is something we can't talk
about yeah i do too yeah yeah uh i can
talk about a thing oh [ __ ] yeah
that rarely happens so uh last week i
filed my
writer's draft of an episode of a
television program that will be called i
think according to the trades
batman the cape crusader
did you see my performance when i was
like what as if i don't know
but i was reacting for them and people
at home you know being being the
everyman at home watching and then kind
of looking giving them a zen mask to
project their feelings onto you were the
eyes and ears of america thank you thank
you but i i know this but before
everyone else
what [ __ ] it
a bat thing an official bat thing an
official bat the first time i've ever
written batman really yeah welcome to
the club
but you're writing a thing that people
will actually see
well done um how did this happen um i
think it happened from the time we had
ed brubaker
on the podcast oh is this the show that
brubaker is like working on in charge ed
brubaker's the showrunner um working
with bruce tim
who's getting to make bruce tim what
does he know about batman
um bruce tim kidz is a co-creator of
batman the animated series justice
league superman adventures every amazing
dc series that uh
uh has defined those characters those
heroes for the last almost 30 years
bruce tim has had a hand in indeed so he
knows more about batman co-creator of
harley quinn by the way yeah yeah um but
so ed one day just [ __ ] texted me and
he's like hey man can you talk
sure ed happy to talk and then an hour
later
he was like because ed likes to talk um
because i think like he lives in carmel
and doesn't get a lot of human
interaction so he just wanted to talk
and he's like hey do you want to write
an episode of this batman show
can you write an episode and i said yeah
yes i can i think i'm free are you
are you paying money not that that's
important you said a little bit
and i said fine
and uh and then we talked a little bit
more and then he ran my name up a
flagpole which apparently there's lots
of flag poles or warner brothers and bad
robot about the people that they want to
be in business with this is a bad robot
joint bad robot jammie jams wow
jj jumping into dc and stuff and he
knows matt reeves then they go back
those two kids yeah
matt reeves was uh he directed uh
cloverfield
oh is that right yeah
huh
take your word for it there you go
um so yeah it's been a really fun dive
into this particular version of batman
that i cannot talk very much about um
even though there are no ndas i'm pretty
sure there's a batarang waiting for me
if i say too much
in public but it's been a riot and and
getting getting to be on zoom calls with
bruce tim where he's giving you notes
about things that batman wouldn't
wouldn't do
is just [ __ ] awesome
did you get [ __ ] yelled at like
batman does not eat [ __ ]
i don't care what the internet says i
think he specifically said that he does
but yeah bruce bruce
is the kind of guy would be like he
totally eats [ __ ] bruce wayne eats
[ __ ] batman does not
hold on hold on i'm trying to think if i
agree with that or not
no
no
no because bruce wayne is the mask right
and so the mask is the playboy and what
playboy cares about eating [ __ ] right
like generally they care about
themselves getting serviced so bruce
wayne i'm sure he keeps the mask up for
appearances and stuff where he's just
like you're not gonna come only i'm
gonna come
but when he's batman that's what he
cares that's when he's about justice
so he's like you're gonna come first
maybe i'll come later batman's about
just us
he's not eating no [ __ ]
um this might be one of the reasons why
matt reeves didn't ask me to write one
of those episodes
um so
were you allowed to do
like any villain you want create a
villain where the parameters are your
life there was a very specific like
here's the story that we want to tell
here's the thing that we think you'd be
great at and i agreed with them because
i wasn't like i don't want to do that
give me the trampoline man and they're
like that's not a villain it's like but
it should be
suzuki's bouncy let me tell you
something if you create trampoline man
and they use it in one of those movies
like matt reeves does a dark version of
trampoline man and [ __ ]
you make some of that riddler money
right there boying [ __ ] boy
uh but yeah there were definitely
guidelines and like here's the story
don't stray too far but within within
this plot like have a good time like
it's trying to invent and embellish and
embroider and
more m words um but yeah just don't [ __ ]
it up and have fun and i hope i didn't
[ __ ] it up i'm supposed to get notes
back next week
and i'll find out if i [ __ ] it up or
not and did they has this been in the
press or anything like that did you ask
him can i say something i asked him can
i say that i wrote an episode and
they're like yeah we don't give a [ __ ]
um
but i can't say much more than has
already been in the press which is bruce
tim and ed brubaker making a batman show
called batman the cape crusader do you
get to see
uh
you know character designs and [ __ ]
early i hope so oh you haven't yet i
haven't yet
at all
i've seen some things but not for this
episode do they have like when they send
you an email that does have a header at
the top with the design of batman or
something yeah
does it look cool
it does yeah can you ask them to send me
one
i'll see what i can do
what the guy [ __ ] would like
we sit here every week and we're always
like man you should [ __ ] write some
[ __ ] now you're writing some [ __ ] give
it up for mark he's writing batman
we'll get to interview you on the show
when the [ __ ] episode comes out we're
already doing it look at that i know
[ __ ] practicing and uh and also this
week star trek picard's second season
premiered
um for which i had a little thing to do
with i was a supervising producer on
that season i believe on twitter i saw a
screenshot
of your credit yeah is that correct that
is did you put it up there or somebody
else uh i put one up because i wanted to
take the perfect shot but i've seen lots
of other people post their versions of
it and it's always flattering and that
anybody recognizes my name anywhere is
always mind-boggling to me so it's not
only do they recognize your name but
they're like actively rooting for you
which is always like charming and it's
always nice
[Laughter]
um it was uh very very nice to see you
you're not connected to the show anymore
but
you had a good time while you were there
right i had a blast i got to i got to go
to starfleet god it seems like a million
years ago that you worked on that show
and now it's finally [ __ ] on that's
that's the weirdness of this job man did
you give that show up to do a different
show or cooler show um i gave that show
up well my contract had come to an end
and they asked me if i wanted to re-up
and i i politely declined only because i
had done another job that i can't talk
about yet right i'm sorry that's just
the way this is gonna go
um
and then got another job after that on a
on a show that i absolutely i can't even
tell you that there was a show
because those people are [ __ ] nuts
about security
i'll react for the internet hmm
wonder who but i [ __ ] know exactly
what he's talking about
but yeah we parted ways very amicably
um and we shared custody could you
imagine there was a [ __ ] time where
you were like uh thank you star trek but
no thank you
like when you stepped away to do
something else i've got to be my own man
star trek
um right on so there's our
that's what's going on in our lives
shall we dive into what's going on in
the
world of pop culture i'm sorry i'm a
little [ __ ] bakey i just picked up
a
right before we came in i smoked a joint
before i got here and then right before
we came in i smoked another tiny joint
with dog walker you know very little
joint uh they call them dog walkers
because like you smoke it while you're
walking your dog and
it's not a whole joint it's tiny right
i was [ __ ] that dog walker was so
sneaky i was just sitting back there
chit-chatting as i was smoking and
[ __ ] just when i walked in i'm like
hey suddenly i was like i'm [ __ ] high
so i'm a little stoney at the moment
it's all good can you drive for a minute
i got this i could be your weed gps my
friend thank you um do we have a sponsor
we have two jesus
right shouldn't have said i was high
take all this information with a grain
of salt ladies and gentlemen um who's
our first sponsor of the evening our
first months are the good folks at
native oh [ __ ] love those people give
it up for native man [ __ ]
[Applause]
batman fights a war on crime [ __ ]
native fights a war on stink
that's that's
better than what they gave what are they
right
when it comes to personal hygiene who
has time to read that long list of
ingredients in the back of the bottle
some ingredients i can't even pronounce
if you're like me and care about what
goes on your body then try native
personal care products every native
product is thoughtfully formulated to
keep you feeling and smelling fresh all
day long
see the batman thing was better yeah
well i mean like they're certainly more
on brand um i'm telling you this native
stuff is fantastic i've seen a few
people tweeting going like all right
[ __ ] fine i'm shy native and then
follow-up tweets but you're just like it
is [ __ ] good my wife swears by it um
i shower with it i have no choice that's
all she has in the shower at this point
and you would think it was the free [ __ ]
that they send us but it's not she
actually goes and buys it and stuff so i
could vouch for it it it's it's good it
smells good and when i use the deodorant
the candy cane deodorant oh
when you have no choice try native deo
yeah let's send them to the actual
website what is it it's nativedeo.com
man if you want to smell and feel fresh
all day long 20 off your first order at
nativedeo.com fat man or use promo code
fat man at checkout
i saw a tweet
uh that said what you i didn't follow
through on it because it looked like you
know it was click bait
but it said uh what part of your body
you wash first says a lot about you
what part of your body do you wash first
when you get in the shower you got your
native you got a [ __ ] palm full of
native where's it going your face your
ass your dick your palms your
titties what do you go for first first
palms because that's how the soap stuff
gets everywhere else right but then
where then my chest
you start here yeah and what hope it
just trickles down to your dick and [ __ ]
i mean what are you then like oh
yeah it's very red shoe diaries
[Music]
[ __ ] native do you use a washcloth or
bare hands bare hands yeah me too yeah
dap
bagel
um yeah man [ __ ] i i i i'm let me
think what i do for you go first put it
in my hands yeah well first thing i do
this is weird first thing i do when i
get in the shower is wash my hands with
a bar of soap because like i'm about to
touch everything okay so i'm like let me
wash my hands you're a surgeon you're
like a medical professional bang you're
scrubbing in i'm about to play doctor so
i'm like i better wash my hands
so i'd wash my hands first and then i
grabbed my [ __ ] native and start i
guess i started my pits yeah how strange
what's the last thing you want dick
really yeah
anybody who's that gotten soap in the
tip of their dick knows that you don't
just let soap linger man like that's a
that's like you a hint of soap to the
dick and then get it out of there before
it [ __ ] gets in the door what are you
doing to your dick when you're [ __ ]
ringing it like
a pipe cleaner just like
i got
like
what
i guess that's too much information no i
mean
i thought it was something everyone
would identify with but apparently
you speak for the audience you're like
why are you touching your dick so much
in the shower it's not supposed to hurt
kevin um native right now is like don't
talk about burning dickholes
that's nothing associated with native
man native only makes you smell good
feel good and [ __ ] and
even your dick will thank you
please talk of your experience with
natives products well what do you love
most about native what is your favorite
scent i love that
my favorite scent is the cookies man
[ __ ] um sugar cookies and uh
it's gonna sound so all right you know
what we should just finish the spot i
was about to get very graphic where i
was like my wife uses the sugar cookies
and her ass smells like sugar cookies
and [ __ ] but native don't want that
either but you wouldn't say that out
there
no but that will sell it will so yeah if
you want
if you want your ass to smell and feel
fresh all day long try native 20 off
your first order by going to
nativedeo.com fat man or promo code fat
men at checkout that's nativedeo.com
fat man or promo code fat man at
checkout for 20 off your first order
your ass can smell like cookies
give it up for the good folks at native
folks
[Applause]
probably the last native spot we'll ever
get jesus christ yeah they're like we
used to like those guys one guy started
talking about his wife's ass and his
[ __ ]
um tuesday night in hollywood exactly we
are in hollywood ladies and gentlemen as
always we're live right now in our home
at the scum and villain in cantina
in hollywood on hollywood boulevard put
your hands gotta let them know you're
real
[Applause]
um jc uh the proprietor of this here bar
uh aka banff man um how goes uh business
man uh pandemic over as far as the bar
is concerned bamf uh hey it's your
bathman give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen
we're uh yeah we've been busy we've been
really busy it's been awesome uh we
started doing a board game night on
mondays where we do like geeky wheel of
fortune
but we call it wheel of fortuna and it's
hosted by a twilik
nice and so you can come in and like
when you say board games you mean like
milton bradley parker brothers yeah
people bring board games in and they
play but we host uh geeky bingo
geeky wheel of fortune and geeky picture
while that's going on so we'll be
playing like board games at a booth and
meanwhile there's also like a live game
going that's dope
one day i'm gonna come to the bar just
as a patron as opposed to like be on the
other side of the bar so to speak to
that be fun man set up shop in a booth
play some sorry
do you remember i think i've ever have
you did you play sorry as a kid [ __ ]
yeah did you really did you not play
sorry that and parcheesi seem like adult
games
i don't mean adult games like you take
your top off and pretend i'm somebody
put it in your dick hole yeah [ __ ]
burning tickle but the games that i like
oh that's what grown-ups play
really yeah it's just [ __ ] colors
dude is that what it was
move this color around here until it
gets home
and if a dude lands on you is like oh
sorry you get to go back to start like
it's not so it's like board game uno
yeah it's not gin rummy or some [ __ ]
didn't rub me i love really yeah because
you're a grown-up boy
yeah my grandmother i used to play that
with my grandmother all the time and um
you know i
one day she was like you you used to be
i could beat you all the time she's like
i can't beat you anymore
and
then she
took off her glasses
and
she saw me look at her glasses and then
she looked at her glasses and she put
them on
and then she looked at her cards and she
looked at me and she realized i was just
seeing her cards reflected
in her glasses all that time and she was
like you little cheat
uh i like that your grandmother's
goldfinger
that's what my grandfather called her
he's like i married old goldfinger for
one reason only i had a conversation
with my mother about this at one point
because my grandfather was a boxer
professional boxer he didn't have a
great record and [ __ ] but he's in like
the boxing hall of fame and stuff like
that he boxed under the name
uh kid dixie um his nickname was dixie
his name was uh
john john or joseph joe
john [ __ ] i forget but schultz was his
last name
um so he left boxing like married my
grandmother and [ __ ] left boxing like
you know
that was family lore forever
my my aunt virginia was born then the
rest of his kids and then my mom later
on
there was never any pushback like my
whole life i was like yeah
he got married and he just quit boxing
and then like i became an entertainer
and you know i'm certainly not the man
in the ring so to speak but i have been
in front of an audience and while it's
not you know a show of physical prowess
the roar of the crowd
would be so difficult to give up once
you felt it and granted he didn't have a
perfect record but he had enough wins
that he would have felt that [ __ ]
energy of the [ __ ] crowd like oh [ __ ]
man like this is where i'm meant to be i
found my place
in the [ __ ] world
and then for some reason he marries my
grandmother and gives that up and later
in life like i questioned that like i
was asking my mom i was like how could
that be and she was like oh you fell in
love with your grandmother and your
grandmother wanted to have a family i
was like yeah [ __ ] man i was like
[ __ ] like my wife wants to do [ __ ]
but like i [ __ ] i'm on my journey
most of the time so like [ __ ] like
nothing's gonna take me off my [ __ ]
path and like if my wife was like i
don't want you to go on stage anymore
i'd be like well then you gotta find a
way to make me feel as good as a
thousand strangers do
you know how to do that you know so
i
it just it didn't
com i didn't comprehend at a certain
point
so i said to my mom
i think i figured it out and she's like
what i was like i think i figured out
why grandpa quit boxing when he married
grandma
it wasn't as simple as she was like i
want you to stop and he just [ __ ]
stopped i was like mom that's impossible
the man had been cheered on by [ __ ]
strangers there's no way he gave that up
willingly and she's like so why why did
he give it up
tiger that's my mother calls me and uh i
said
mom i'm pretty sure
it was all about anal
and she's like come again i was like he
did with grandma over and over
and i think grandma might have been one
of them dirty german broads man because
maybe she did some [ __ ] others wouldn't
and he was like you know [ __ ] i'm a
boxer and she's like not anymore you're
gonna stay home if you want this ass
and he was like
and he [ __ ] hung up the gloves
because he just wanted it so badly my
mother was just like those are my
parents you're talking
about that's like they're my
grandparents man
at home exactly man
that's my theory anyway i uh i'll i'll
buy it right checks out
uh should we talk about a movie that we
saw yeah i guess so
i guess people in [ __ ] tune in to
hear about my grandpa um
we saw the batman ladies and gentlemen
as as
i'm sure did most of the world um
although i just went to the weed store
tonight uh i lifted is my favorite weed
store and uh the
the guy mikey who works there
um he was like what are you doing
tonight i was like oh we're going to do
a live show he goes where i was like
it's coming villainy cantina he's like
what's it called it's fat man beyond it
goes well you do i said we talk about
like geeky stuff like he's like what are
you talking about this week and i was
like oh the batman and he goes that come
out
and i was like holy [ __ ] mikey yeah made
like [ __ ] all the money in the world
man he's going gotta check that out
and i'm like that's so strange to
encounter like i live in a world where
everybody's like i gotta [ __ ] i'll step
on your neck to see it
and there's still some people out there
being like no [ __ ] a new batman movie go
figure so it astonishes you that a dude
who works at a weed store doesn't care
much that there's a new batman movie out
i don't know i'm a weed store patron and
all i cared about was this [ __ ]
batman movie coming out yeah but he's
not just a client
he's the president of that
it was uh for those anybody here not see
the batman put your hands together real
quick
uh i mean kids sorry yeah we're gonna
have to spoil the [ __ ] out of this
anybody at home look we waited
considering like we saw it earlier
thanks to claire uh uh bateman king who
took us to
uh the uh chinese theater uh me and mark
and ralph
um went and sat in the [ __ ] balcony
at the
chinese it's a secret balcony where like
sid groman
had like the guy who started it grow
man's chinese theater where he'd have
his private parties and [ __ ] like that
and we met some of the tcl people at tcl
chinese theater and uh got to sit in
this [ __ ] sweet pocket where you're
literally looking at the [ __ ]
chandelier man it's killer
um best possible way to see it uh
because it's an imax venue
then i saw the very next day thanks to
our good friend brett deacon who works
at 40x he set up a [ __ ] 40x screening
for us to go watch so we saw it with
those [ __ ] chairs that
mimic everything that's going on in the
movie which during the car chase was
[ __ ] nuts but for most of the time
was just kind of this
is it he's like he's reaching for a clue
and it takes like 10 minutes for you to
get a clue it was a lot
of chair floating and [ __ ] but
40x also like does atmosphere yeah so
like it does rain and i don't know if
you've seen this movie but there's a
[ __ ] ton of rain man
i think the new york times [ __ ]
review headline was who stopped the
wayne um
which i thought was funny um a lot of
[ __ ] rain so as we were sitting there
watching the movie in 4dx
like it's shooting [ __ ] water in your
face it was dope and stuff i hope you
didn't wash your dick in the 40s
yes
one could have taken a shower so uh i
saw
it twice back to back before it opened
and it was hard for us to not talk about
it but we assumed most people would be
seeing it on friday or this weekend and
stuff and then we gave them an extra day
so it's tuesday
if you haven't seen it yet where the
[ __ ] are your priorities uh
um so yeah we are gonna spoil it kids so
if you don't want spoiled
don't tune out or cover yours or go
outside or grab a smoke for the next
hour and uh
because we're gonna dive into uh the
batman ladies and gentlemen um
bam
oh
banff man is here to interrupt the
batman what's up so i had um i had like
the equivalent of a twitter rubbing salt
in the wound where you guys
had tweeted a picture from behind of
three shadows which was like guess who's
seeing the batman early
and my ats on twitter just blew up
because everybody's like oh it's kevin
mark and jc
for like three days
and i didn't get to go because jen my
fiance had fallen and hit her face yeah
and i was like
i can continue to have a partner in life
or i can go see batman
and so i chose the former
um smart call i just imagine that you
stayed home going why do we fold jen
so we can get back up again
oh my god
wrong one
so then andrew texted me last night and
he was like i'm gonna go see batman
before it gets spoiled do you want to go
and i was like i
i can't go and see a movie a three-hour
movie at 10 o'clock at night like
the [ __ ] happened to you
so my response was i said i'm guessing
batman does some detective stuff makes a
mistake learns a lesson and puts the bad
guys in jail and andrew goes did you
write that movie
you know give it up for andrew man
andrew in the [ __ ] booth who makes it
all happen
and also you're wrong andrew
um you want to go first
sorry
mine's gonna be long-winded
uh all right i i guess i will start with
i've seen it twice now yeah i saw it
once uh in the chinese and then once i
went um opening night i went friday
night
and
there was some stuff that i actually do
love about this movie and i know they
actually it feels like it's a disclaimer
because y'all know who i am by this
point right like it's not really that
much of a surprise i would say there
were a lot of [ __ ] tweets i saw a
week of people going like
i know what you think kevin but
i can't wait to see what mark says
um
i just i think my my headline is
we seem to now be hopefully at the end
of the road of what if batman was real
because for me the more real batman is
the less interested i am in him
because he's not in this movie
specifically
there is nothing special about batman
he's just a guy in body armor who can
fight kind of okay
who drives a muscle car that's got too
much muscle for him
who like solves really simple riddles
and doesn't catch any of the bad guys
i gotta tell you i
when i when you know we're watching the
movie for the first time and the first
[ __ ] clue is
revealed or in the card where he's like
what does a
dead man
do
what does a lying man do when he's dead
yeah and instantly
i turned to [ __ ] mark and i was like
he lies still
and i felt smarter than the batman
because it took the world's greatest
detective another 20 seconds to [ __ ]
figure that [ __ ] out
what is blind and denied and blah blah
justice yeah
come on no he didn't say that he goes
the answer is justice
all proper and [ __ ] as if he was on
jeopardy yeah and like this this is a
movie in which batman
knocks on doors
crime doors right like there's criminals
back there doing criminal [ __ ] and he's
like
can i come in i'm sad batman please i'm
looking to punch some faces please
and like and then they open the door and
then he beats a bunch of people up and
then he comes back again and knocks on
the door again
he's like
[Music]
what is how
i took that as uh like matt reeves being
like all right let's just acknowledge
how ridiculous this concept is because
he shows up knocks at the door
dressed as batman he's like do you know
who i am
and they're like yeah [ __ ] and i
give him a hard time which like why
would you ever like just [ __ ] if you
know who he is [ __ ] step aside you
idiot
but instead they [ __ ] get mouthy and
they get [ __ ] they [ __ ] around and
find out and [ __ ]
but then later on he comes to the same
[ __ ] door same [ __ ] club same
[ __ ] knock but now he's bruce wayne
and then the same voice goes
do you know who i am
and they're like hey [ __ ] bruce like
so stoked to see him um i wished he had
changed his voice a little bit
um for that reason alone because you
know if i'm at the door if i'm one of
those twins at the door
and that dude comes back and then says
it
it definitely jogs my memory and all i
do is this and say say it again
and then like i [ __ ] knew it you know
you got a real jawline buddy
uh but back to you sorry um
yeah and and like i love that it was a
detective story yeah i mean i i that is
the one thing that has not been a part
of the batman cinematic mythos is i'm
solving [ __ ] crimes i mean in in um
what was it the dark knight
he does that like ridiculously expensive
high-end bullet reassembly thing
where he like cuts out cement and then
[ __ ]
recreates the shots and [ __ ] like that
and then matches it kinda and then has
the computer do a simulation and then
somehow is able to pull a fingerprint
off a bullet that he doesn't [ __ ]
have and [ __ ] like that it was so
convoluted but i was like i guess that's
detective work yeah sure
he detected something i don't know how
but [ __ ] he figured out it's already
done yeah that [ __ ] riddle was more
complicated than any riddle the riddler
did in this movie yeah and i remember
leaning into you at the end of it it was
like he like the riddle asked the
riddler asked a riddle that bruce never
solves
which is what's black and blue and dead
all over yeah
and and mark had a good answer for it
answer was it's you
but honestly it's you got a black mayor
you got a bunch of cops in blue uniforms
and they're all going to die in the
middle of madison square garden
that's the answer to that riddle and you
didn't what what is this and then i
stopped asking that question
um
but ultimately like
i would have forgiven all of those sins
if the movie's third act if a finale
landed for me
because this movie wants to be seven
it's trying to be seven really badly and
i'm here for like the seven cover
version of this movie
except that seven is the best batman
movie we've ever gotten
seven is about morgan freeman as batman
brad pitt is robin fighting the [ __ ]
riddler slash joker that's that movie
and that city hold on hold on
[Laughter]
i buy that i buy that like i think it
tracks yeah right and so then when john
doe gives himself up
it makes sense because the finale of
that movie is about breaking the spirit
of both batman and robin and he does it
and the finale of this movie is
i guess i'm gonna shoot the mayor not
really though and i guess that a bunch
of these goons are gonna
i don't know bungee down and cause some
mayhem and i guess batman's gonna punch
people we've never met before
and we're supposed to feel great about
this like it's supposed to feel like a
finale
where he i guess transforms from a
similar vengeance into a symbol of hope
by being an emt in gotham city
yeah that that whole thing i mean that
aspect where he was just like um i
understood the whole
he's in the beginning of the movie he's
like i'm vengeance and then they [ __ ]
mock him with it for the rest of the
movie it was like a vengeance suck my
dick and [ __ ] like that
but but like by the end of the movie one
of the riddlers is like i'm vengeance
and then you cut to him and he's like oh
maybe i shouldn't say that anymore
and the lesson that he learns i'm all
for it i understood it perfectly that
being said
fundamentally i don't agree that he's a
symbol of hope
like superman is a symbol of hope batman
has never been a symbol of hope batman
is a symbol of you [ __ ] up hardcore
because if you're seeing him that's it
you're [ __ ] seeing him for that
reason i do love the shot of him
carrying somebody what looked like a kid
um you know after the the flood from
nowhere and stuff like that like i do
love the notion of batman holding a kid
particularly because of his tie
to childhood trauma but that being said
like
to me batman is most effective when he's
like the dark avenger in the shadows um
i i i bitchin i do love the fact that
like he was in the light so much in this
movie and that he was just batman
through most of the movie and he'll
stand around cops as batman it's so
weird though because i know because if i
was the cop i'd be like
that's bruce wayne yeah and even if you
don't do that like he just punches
people for fun i guess yeah maybe we
should arrest him possibly for lots of
assault and battery i love that though i
do love like that straight out the
comics man when like batman walks in and
they're all like [ __ ] jim what are
you doing and he's like he's with me and
he's [ __ ] like vouching for him and
everybody else is like this [ __ ] the
one thing that i never agree with when
they do it in all the movies and i think
it's just because you can't curse in
these movies but they're always like
freak
and i'm like why is that a [ __ ] freak
the dude is wearing more body armor than
you i call that [ __ ] smart man
like it's not freak it's if anything
it's just like
[ __ ] spoiled or something like that
but it's not really freakish you know
they're both on the same side they're
both like
fighting bad guys just he wears the mask
that's about it but i think like that's
that's the problem when you make it real
because then he looks ridiculous
because then it's why do you need the
batwings well if you're not about
inspiring fear which clearly you're not
really because nobody seems afraid of
you
then why why the bad thing
why not just a [ __ ] helmet why not no
cape why because capes are stupid
no cakes
all of that makes sense except for like
i the idea of i need to be theatrical
because if he takes off the mask mark
he's just [ __ ] reacher at that point
right like
[Laughter]
yeah be reacher
like look we would all like to be
reacher but because you know what
doesn't happen to reach her he doesn't
get [ __ ] sucker punched by street
thugs on a subway platform i love that
though i love that he gets that man
getting his ass kicked he's always got
it he's always got to take a bite he
doesn't get his ass kicked but he always
has to [ __ ] take a punch they every
batman takes punch remember [ __ ]
bat fleck got stabbed in the [ __ ]
shoulder he's like ah
then he pulls it out and [ __ ]
re-stabs the other guy
that was [ __ ] metal as [ __ ] man yeah
but there's always somebody always gets
a point remember in the dark knight
[ __ ] like the one joker pushes the
one clown at him he [ __ ] gets a lucky
punch right in [ __ ] batman's chin and
you're like holy [ __ ] even that guy but
he would get one lucky punch i mean just
think about it for all the
for all the people that that dude's
taking on to get hit once or twice is
pretty
you gotta throw in a world where you're
going like this is realistic and i saw a
tweet which i think really described the
movie quite well um sometimes the words
of somebody else will do it and i wish i
remember who wrote it but they their
theory was
chris nolan
put batman in the real world
matt reeves made batman's world
real
let that track for a minute do you agree
um oh yeah no it makes sense i'm just
saying i don't like it yeah yeah
but i mean it's just like uh like nolan
was like the first one who's like what
if this [ __ ] was real like what if we
shot it in chicago not on a [ __ ]
sound stage what if we just made it like
this [ __ ] exists in the real world when
i saw batman begins my take away review
was oh my god they they made batman as
if it was a cop movie like this is just
a cop movie and he just happens to have
a cape and a mask that's it because it
was such a realistic approach
this you know thank you i felt was
i felt was very much in the vein of
chris nolan trying to be like yeah man
let's keep this [ __ ] real but that tweet
i thought summed it up better which was
like
they didn't he didn't try to make it as
real as much as he tries to make the
world of batman
real like even down to the villains and
stuff like that which
you know i i guess you're right the the
how much more real can it [ __ ] get
like sooner or later he'll just use the
mass because lose the mass because that
wouldn't be
real but you need a some injection of
unreality otherwise it's like
where's the [ __ ] fun like that's
that's that's what to me the mask is
about
um you know it takes it into the realm
of [ __ ] fantasy because generally
speaking people don't wear [ __ ] masks
which you know when they go [ __ ]
fight crime which they should like and
not to protect somebody's identity but
just a [ __ ] face shield and [ __ ]
which they do like riot cops wear
[ __ ] masks like we've seen what
militarized police look like yeah and
they are not very far from what batman
is and that was my point the only
difference he's not wearing hockey pads
this [ __ ] new batman is wearing
hockey pads yeah and a batarang that
does a thing once
he pulls it out yeah it's a exacto knife
and [ __ ] pulls it out twice twice i'm
sorry
um
but i think like and again if if the
last part of that last chunk of that
movie worked for me emotionally i could
forgive so much more but it functionally
for the first two hours of that film and
it should not need to be three hours
he's just a cop
he's just a guy in a case
and it's abstract for him it doesn't
mean anything to him other than it seems
like people are dying and i guess the
police are upset and he never stops
anybody from dying because they just
keep dying but he's never emotionally
engaged with what's happening until it's
i saw the boy at the funeral and i feel
bad for him
but i didn't stop anybody from killing
his parents i never did the thing that i
thought i was going to do
which is ever have anybody feel this way
again
you know and so what i what i was hoping
for and they seem to kind of toe up to
it is
this is about privilege
and and so the people in gotham who have
privilege are the ones who are being
attacked
and it only becomes personal once it
becomes about his dad but it could have
been personal much earlier it could have
been like because i don't give a [ __ ]
about the mayor or the police chief or
whomever else like but if you told me
that the founding families of gotham
were all being wiped out by their
riddler
and thomas wayne and his son bruce were
next on the list
and so he had to be bruce wayne for a
second
like the duality of bruce wayne and
batman is what makes me excited about
batman and when robert pattinson got
cast it's like oh
batman could kind of be anybody in that
suit i want to see his bruce wayne
and i never saw his bruce wayne because
the movie was resolved and we were just
going to be in batman's pov which is a
choice and i can respect the choice but
for me a batman story isn't really a bad
mister unless you get both
unless you get both an equal measure and
so for a guy who rejects
the the the richers the riches of his
family and the privilege that he had to
have to accept it and pretend to live in
it to smoke out a bad guy
like all right i'll watch that because
now it's about him it's not about other
people
so i saw a tweet where uh you know
somebody was like not enough
bruce wayne and then the person
responded said well that's the point of
the whole [ __ ] movie
there's not enough bruce wayne he's not
he hasn't learned to be bruce wayne yet
all he does is wants to be batman
and i was like oh all right like i wish
they would have said that in the movie
but i guess i'll buy that like that's
pretty that's a pretty on point his
emotional arc at the end of the movie
not be i need to be a symbol of hope and
help carry people out of burning
buildings but i need to be [ __ ] bruce
wayne i need to stand next to this mayor
and say i am going to live up to what my
father hoped to do which has helped
breathe new life into this city i'm
going to fix that fund or whatever of
both parts of my heritage i'm going to
both be the dark avenger and be gotham's
son
and then you get to have the full circle
of it you get for him to have to realize
that bruce wayne is necessary it's a
mask i have to wear for the days that i
can't be [ __ ] batman because batman
can't actually do everything
there's a moment where he gets into it
with alfred he gets into alfred he gets
into it with alvin quite a bit in this
movie
um always [ __ ] hen pecking at him and
[ __ ]
um but alfred's like you know you got to
keep up appearances you wear these wayne
cufflinks
and he's like are you a wayne alfred and
it's like [ __ ] you [ __ ] like
i [ __ ] changed your diaper man like
[ __ ] i was like this with your dad
told you how to take a bomb in the face
yeah [ __ ] the only reason you're
punching people on the street is because
of what i [ __ ] you
but he's very patient [ __ ] alfred's
superpower is patience with bruce in
this movie
um there's you know even when he wakes
up i was the one thing i you know i i
like i like
my
surrogate dad alfred
story lines i i like that he was always
giving alfred
[ __ ] alfred almost you know spoilers
gets [ __ ] killed you know he's barely
in the [ __ ] flick and [ __ ] he
wakes up in the hospital and he looks
over at bruce and
he manages a [ __ ] smile the first
thing out of bruce's mouth is you lied
to me
and i'm like you emo [ __ ] [ __ ] ask
him how he feels man
lubin up a little bit
jesus he changed your diaper um
but uh yeah that that i i did i could
have used a little bit less yeah i mean
so like listen is that real like you
know that
that
maybe that makes it more real like
because they're like look he even says
in the movie he's like i don't care what
happens to me and [ __ ]
so to the point that he's like i don't
even give a [ __ ] about alfred but it
would have been nice at the end of the
movie if he was like you know what
alfred
you know [ __ ] you don't have to weep
her and i just [ __ ] let him know like
what would have been great for me
was a post post-credits scene where he's
like it was so shitty how when you woke
up in the hospital the first thing i
said was
[ __ ] you lied to me so here and he
throws them like a circus party and [ __ ]
like that
very colorful very or a post-credit
scene where just bruce is laying in
alfred's lap like he used to when he was
a kid just just cradled me alfred
just one last time or a post-credits
scene where like bruce wakes up in the
hospital and alfred's sitting there and
he's like you're a [ __ ] and then he
walks
out lied to you about so much more than
you did
um but yeah listen i i i appreciate much
of what this movie was trying to do yeah
and there's there's a great skill being
deployed in making this movie it's
gorgeous to look at i think that car
chase i remember we talked about it
after seeing it was like it's still
confusing so weird but on the second
time like they did a [ __ ] car chase
in the rain which is impossible to do
yeah like production wise it's just it's
so astonishingly hard yeah to make that
work i did not need the shot where bruce
like dramatically walks over to the car
and like his [ __ ] spurs jingling on
the journey
and he says his cape is right there
and then he just leans in
oh hello y'all right there
it's just you gotta cut before the lean
because it's not that cool
um
and i and i dug zoe kravitz as catwoman
even though like
is she a cat burglar or not a cat
burglar is she a person who does crime
for a living or is she a waitress if
she's a waitress why does she have crime
[ __ ] in a bag if she's got crime [ __ ] in
a bag why is she a waitress right
i mean just square that circle was she
correct me if i'm wrong was she
undercover the whole time trying to find
her mother's killer
that's what i got by the end of the
movie
which she killed because the guy who
killed her mom got killed and
he almost killed her but yeah i mean
maybe although it doesn't it seems like
she's all about finding out who killed
her girlfriend
that as well
but that still doesn't explain why she's
got safe cracking tools and still lives
in a shitty apartment in what seems to
be queens
with a bunch of cats
that was funny though like you got a lot
of cats
i like cats that i mean i guess that did
count as like humor in this movie
there's not a ton yeah it's pretty it's
a pretty dour flick in terms of uh the
laugh factors but nobody goes to a
batman movie to laugh anyway
um so i wasn't too put off by that no
but like
it seems as if in batman movies of the
modern era the black guy's job is to
provide punch lines for the dour white
guy
because there's great scenes with morgan
freeman as lucius fox in in the in the
nolan trilogy he's like you mean to tell
me that you think a billionaire who runs
around a night won a bat costume
and you're going to extort this man good
luck good luck
yeah
no guns nah man that's your thing i'm a
cop yeah
jeffrey wright i think was an absolute
treasure in this movie um now it's just
like wow he should play jim gordon
forever
uh yeah he was wonderful and their
chemistry was really nice uh throughout
um and i i do like the fact that
him and gordon work closely together
that's something you rarely
see we saw a little bit of course with
uh what's as [ __ ] um
uh
gary oldman um but like in the original
batman movies like tim burton batman
movie remember batman returns like after
he [ __ ] aces the
red triangle circus gang
[ __ ] he's walking away and like
[ __ ] commissioner gordon is chasing
after him well thank you for saving the
city batman and he's like yeah yeah yeah
he was trying to zerk his guy back he's
like we'll see he [ __ ] off man he
treats him like [ __ ] alfred and [ __ ]
in this movie
um so it's nice to see them working
together um as as partners closely and
him vouching for him with the cops
um there was you know i had little logic
issues with some [ __ ] like for example
at one point
batman gets knocked out unconscious when
the [ __ ] dude's neck cuff blows up
and [ __ ]
and
he wakes up in a completely different
room yes far from where they were
holding the funeral city hall in city
hall so maybe let's say he's a floor
down even if you want to keep him close
he's in the same building but they took
him out of that room
he's laying on a [ __ ] table
surrounded by cops and just as he's
coming to
which one has to assume the travel from
one place to another he's out for 10
minutes minimum so let's say [ __ ]
five minimum
just as he's waking up somebody finally
has the [ __ ] idea like let's take his
mask off and then he's like oh no you
know
he goes all emo and starts slapping
everybody and [ __ ]
um that that to me was like [ __ ] if
all these cops hate him as much as they
[ __ ] do the moment this guy goes out
first thing they do is yank that [ __ ]
mask off even after the pretense of like
maybe his face is on fire under that
mask because of the explosion or
something like that
um that's the first thing they open up
you think they don't pull his pants down
take his mask off and then look at his
dick
um
that was a tiny thing that i i [ __ ]
bumped into i when the movie started
i was uh [ __ ] thrilled
by
his voiceover
when he was reading like his journals
that's one of my favorite aspects of any
batman comic book is is bruce wayne as
omniscient
narrator and they rarely do that
in the i don't know if they've ever done
that in the batman movies have they they
did it like you know we had it in
watchmen with uh the rorschach
was essentially doing the batman
monologue head monologue and stuff but
they've have they ever done that in a i
don't think so batman movie i don't
think he's a journalist
in those in the other ones it's such an
easy thing to add and it really could
help plot holes and [ __ ] because you can
jump in at any point not reshoot
something just have him be like oh by
the way off camera
some [ __ ] happened you don't need to see
anyways
but i went to little seasons and i got
one of those bad calzones which is weird
but i was hungry
and then i found more crime and i
punched it in the face a lot
and now i'm sad and i'm sleepy so i'm
going to go home
listen to the cure
maybe draw on my floor
because i need a murder board but i
don't have a boards on the floor so [ __ ]
it
bat bat carrie mathison
he did he he
took off the took the carpet i thought
that was a real stretch too where it's
just like he was killed by this [ __ ]
carpet tool and they're like wait a
second carpet tool there's a [ __ ]
carpet in this room
and they rip it open and there's the
[ __ ] riddler's plan on the floor and
[ __ ] was that weirder than you don't
know spanish it's not ella's law
that was a that i thought was enjoyable
i was like you know what i loved when he
was like world's greatest detectives
he seemed to be having a [ __ ] blast
i mean
god bless colin farrell man he was just
in there having the time of his life and
unrecognizable whole [ __ ] movie i
never like never once was like that's
colin farrell under there yeah i'm sure
somewhere russell crowe was like [ __ ]
you colin farah yeah
i could have done that without breaking
a [ __ ] sweat
um he was having a good time um
who else is having a good time in that
movie
pattinson uh very committed to the role
i've always liked him as an actor um he
delivered i liked his batman i i if i
subscribed to that theory of like he was
so driven there was no bruce wayne
i'm fine i'll buy that for the movie but
next movie i want to see him bruce wayne
it up i want to see him be [ __ ]
charming yeah just once yeah i know it's
in there and like i those are the i you
know what was his name bale did it
really well
when he's like so everybody please go
it's not a joke get out of my house like
[ __ ] like that
and um and then even when he was like he
came in for the harvey dent party and he
was just like yeah great slogan harvey
like he he was or when he was like i'm
buying the rest of the hotel he he was
able to pull off like bruce wayne a feat
[ __ ] really well i thought ben did a
wonderful job as drunk playboy ben
affleck
bruce wayne
oops
freudian slip um
when he was in bvs when like you know
what was it lex luthor or his assistant
mercy like catches him and uh
[Laughter]
instantly he drops drunk face and he
goes back to like batman face and [ __ ]
so i look forward to seeing what rob
pattinson will do with bruce wayne in
the next movie i you know
my whole life
i've been watching batman's stuff since
i was a kid of course the adam west
iterations uh the super friends i've
loved this character forever they
started making these batman pictures not
counting the batman you know uh the the
spin-off movie from the tv series
um
they started making him 1989 with tim
burton's batman and i'll never forget
seeing that in a movie theater
i was working at domino's pizza and i
quit
day one i was there were many trainees
and they were just like look we have too
many trainees who wants to go home and i
didn't want to wear slacks ever so i was
very happy i was like you know what i'll
go because the dominoes was three
parking lots away from the middletown
movie multiplex where my friends brian
and walter were already in line to see
[ __ ] batman and [ __ ] there were no
cell phones so i couldn't be like hold
me a place i like screeched my [ __ ]
car through the parking lot and had to
look for them in a line of 400 people
and be like hold me a seat and [ __ ]
everybody's like [ __ ] you because they
were lying behind them still
went to see that movie loved every
[ __ ] second of it sat there going
like my god
somebody did batman serious
it's so dark
it's just like the comics and [ __ ] like
that and you know
it's a quaint notion now because when
you watch it
it's darkened as much as like they're on
a sound stage and they keep it dimly lit
but
you know
jack nicholson is chewing the [ __ ]
scenery with the performance of a
[ __ ] lifetime
michael keaton was my batman for many
many years still is can't wait to see
him in the flash or and batgirl as well
um i was a big believer
in the michael keaton batman because
i like him michael keaton is a dramatic
actor he was amazing and clean and sober
and that's how he got into that batman
role and stuff
but um
they took batman and and made him even
more approachable for everybody
because you know was
time was he had to be this [ __ ] big
strapping dude mike keaton's batman is a
dude who puts on body armor and suddenly
like oh my god [ __ ] anybody could be
batman you know if you got a lot of
money and your parents are dead and [ __ ]
like that
so loved that movie and became my
religion um you know redecorated my room
[ __ ] batman 89 style
when uh batman returns came out in 92 i
saw that in vancouver
um when i was going to film school saw
it with scott moser and whatnot the bat
the cat and the penguin
um
you know was irritated by the fact that
he ripped off a rubber mask in the third
act where it's like that [ __ ] thing's
supposed to be bulletproof oh they
[ __ ] it up
tiny minor errors and [ __ ] has one of my
favorite moments in a batman movie of
all time
just highlighting how ludicrous the
whole situation is batman's in the bat
skiff going through the [ __ ] sewers
of gotham heading toward the penguin you
know for the big battle [ __ ] penguins
with missiles on their back rise out of
the water and fire missiles at the bat
skiff and he [ __ ] pulls the steering
wheel back and spins it so he avoids
the [ __ ] missiles and the bat skiff
like writes itself goes past the
penguins and they watch it go and [ __ ]
such an amazing little moment and then
they cut to inside the bat skiff
as it's writing itself and michael
keaton for one brief glorious second
looks back like what the [ __ ] was that
and then [ __ ]
keeps going and [ __ ] and it was so
wonderfully human um but that was the
one where they went dark and everybody
was like oh this shit's too dark so the
next batman movie of course is batman
forever and i remember seeing that in
the theater and being like oh [ __ ]
like i love the fact that he called
one of two faces gang members called him
face
in the opening few minutes of the movie
[ __ ] the cape back cape covers the
helicopter and the [ __ ] guy driving
it turns around and goes face and
two-face looks and sees the cape that
[ __ ] made my heart soar because i was
like oh my god that sounds like the
[ __ ] comics and then when [ __ ] val
kilmer like headbutts the windshield and
[ __ ] goes you need help harvey it was
like
he called [ __ ] two-face harvey like
this is [ __ ] insane
um and then jim it became the jim carrey
show and it's totally enjoyable riddler
movie and stuff
but you know you could see
you get into a third act where it's like
wow the third act is more like the old
batman tv show with a you know a [ __ ]
death trap and [ __ ] like that
i'm sure that means nothing and then
batman and robin happens a few years
later and it's just batman the tv show
they've gone full circle and taking it
right back to that including dutch tilts
and [ __ ]
puns galore and stuff and it's like
watching your hero die in real time
you're like i didn't think anything
could kill the batman but something
[ __ ] did
um and then batman went away for a red
hot minute although we did have batman
mask of the phantasm in there as well
which was an amazing batman movie and i
saw that in the theater by myself um
it came out like christmas day yeah
a lot of people were with their families
i was like i'm with my father
um
batman begins comes out
and i go see the movie and like i said
before i'm like jesus man it's like
somebody did it batman real serious
like [ __ ] did it as if it's like a
cop movie as if it happens in the real
world this is [ __ ] up this is you know
there's nothing there's not even a sound
stage everything about this is new and
different
um but i didn't like you know i wasn't
in love with batman begins i respected
batman begins respected the [ __ ] out of
it and was happy that somebody was doing
the character the way i always dreamed
they'd do the character as real as
[ __ ] raincoats man like holy [ __ ]
this batman makes sense in the real
[ __ ] world
um
then the dark knight came out and i
remember going to see that out here with
uh
peter shiretta run slash film
um and he was like hey man we got space
in a in a press screen you want to go
and i was like [ __ ] yeah i met him over
in century city
and it was me and a bunch of film
bloggers from all those sites that were
out around that time
and i remember you know [ __ ] being
absolutely
blown away every moment of that [ __ ]
movie
even something as simple as like you
know the bat
the batmobile chase sequence on lower
whacker drive and you're watching like
you know [ __ ] play out in in a place
i've driven in the real world and seen
um and it's a fantastic chase with
[ __ ] bazookas and [ __ ] the joker
going crazy and knocking vehicles right
into the [ __ ] water and [ __ ]
and then just when it's over just when
you're like oh [ __ ] man i [ __ ] the
batmobile's down for the count the car
starts [ __ ] vibrating and suddenly
those billboards that you saw for months
of batman riding a [ __ ] bat pod with
these giant tires and being like what
the [ __ ] is that all about
instantly makes sense when you're like
oh my god it's the tires of the
batmobile it's an eject pod holy [ __ ]
and another [ __ ] chase sequence kicks
in that's even better than the one that
just [ __ ] finished
heath ledger's performance the
scenery chewing performance
that kind of takes what nicholson did
and makes it serious and frightening
almost horror uh horror movie scary uh
in his approach to the character creepy
always licking his lips which we all
know now is to keep the [ __ ]
prosthetics in place
everything about that movie was was
amazing it's not just a great comic book
movie it's one of the greatest motion
pictures ever made captures the the
essence of everything a fantasy movie or
a movie in general should do take you to
a place
take you on an adventure you'll never
see
in the real world and he managed to do
it through a lens that made it look like
our world
so we got him for a while and of course
dark knight rises came out and that was
almost a religious experience
uh for me because it was the end of that
trilogy that i loved so much that i
started out going like that's fine then
fell in love with by the second movie
and so much so that the third movie i
was able to forgive any flaws whatsoever
because i was so [ __ ] pop committed
to nolan's vision of batman and then tom
hardy's [ __ ] bane which was
you know
not as scenery chewing as heath ledger's
joker but
fascinating
character study in and of itself by a
wonderful actor which elevated the
motion picture on the whole
zack snyder does batman v superman and i
get to see
one of my closest friends in the world
[ __ ] be one of the most
cinematically accurate versions of
batman we've ever seen the outfit the
[ __ ] physical care the physicality
um he moves like the video game camera a
video game character and [ __ ]
punishes people equally as [ __ ] hard
um it was the closest
to the dark knight returns batman that
we'd enjoyed in comics for so [ __ ]
long um i'll never forget seeing the
trailer for it at [ __ ] comic-con
before bvs came out and seeing that shot
of [ __ ]
batman like swinging and then firing it
grappling and and swinging off just
before
do what we'd later find out was doomsday
[ __ ] blows that thing apart
it was absolute
[ __ ] magic
seeing that batman
come to life uh justice league you know
we know what happened there
but then seeing like zack snyder's
four-hour cut like [ __ ] gives you the
batman that you
were promised in bvs so then we come to
this to the batman which months ago they
showed us trailers for and instantly
everybody identified as like holy [ __ ]
it's batman
as seven or seven as batman it's they're
going dark with this and they're going
to do
ciphers with the riddler and and [ __ ]
uh the zodiac killer type approach
and
it looked as real
as the nolan [ __ ]
like whereas zach you know took a detour
into
a world that made it look like comic
book come to life zach paints and splash
pages and so
his stuff
um is very
comic booky and i don't mean that as
dismissive by any stretch of the
imagination it looks like a comic book
come to life
matt reeves hasn't given us what looks
like a comic book coming to life unless
you're thinking of like remember when
paul pope did batman the very wispy thin
batman man 100 yes kind of has that kind
of look and feel to it
but i agree with that [ __ ]
tweet where the person said like
he ain't trying to do it in the real
world he's trying to make batman's world
real
and i think he succeeded i liked the
movie
um i'm not like absolutely in love with
it like i was the dark knight but that's
not a criticism of of the movie itself
dark knight is maybe once in a lifetime
[ __ ] experience you get if you're
lucky
this carries on the tradition uh that
nolan started incredibly proudly while
adding new wrinkles to it and new
flourishes new touches
that
that matt reeves or bat reeves brings to
this
version
having watched it twice
my
only real hardcore criticism of the
movie this comes from a person
who cut his [ __ ] feature down to like
93 minutes and [ __ ]
that's a long [ __ ] movie
and you know if somebody had told me
like when they did tell me you're gonna
get a three-hour batman movie i was like
oh i'm gonna come for three hours
straight
but there's there's you know there's you
could have definitely made a two-hour
movie of that and lost not really losing
much
invisible edits i'm not saying take out
a whole [ __ ] sequence although
you know the the third act seemed to
come out of nowhere that was the general
consensus when we all watched it at uh
the chinese theater me
mark and ralph was like
i think mark put it best he's like it
feels like matt reeves was trying to
make a 50 million dollar version of
batman
and then some studio note came down
where it's like well where's the
spectacle you need spectacle and then
all of a sudden there's this third act
where a sea wall which we've never heard
about
um there was no set up for it's not like
when the mayor was walking with bruce
wayne she's like i could really help use
your help on the sea wall campaign you
know it's not very strong and he's like
i'm busy or something like that
no setup whatsoever all of a sudden he's
like i set up some vans near the sea
wall you're all [ __ ] and all of a
sudden gotham is flooded and i get that
like they've shown us many views of
gotham as an island and bridges and [ __ ]
but like
you know yeah little morning's supposed
to be in manhattan a little more
saturn's not going to get flooded
give us a little bit more setup to be
like why that [ __ ] sea wall means
something
um but i it did feel like we got a a
mini sequel it felt like the movie
reconciles itself
once the [ __ ] riddler's in jail and
he's like
no we were working together and he's
like you're [ __ ] nuts like there it
is there's your movie and then all of a
sudden there's a mini sequel where a
disaster happens to gotham that is
beyond simple detective work and
requires
heroism requires you know
him to light a [ __ ] flare and lead
people through the water and [ __ ] like
that like requires him to dive into the
water cut electrical cables and and move
things to save people and stuff requires
a baptism
if you will yeah
a baptism
um
that that that to me was like
you could have ended before that
and
i it would have been absolutely fine uh
it's not like them going into the flood
ruined it or anything like that
but it was just like just when i was
like right on man this [ __ ] movie's
dope it's wrapping up all of a sudden
they were like sit back down
here comes the sequel and [ __ ] all of
a sudden a whole other movie happened so
no complaints there you know [ __ ] all
anyone ever wants is you know [ __ ] i
want to see my money's worth and [ __ ]
and this [ __ ] movie gives you your
money's worth even if you went to see it
at amc and they charged you two dollars
more and [ __ ] this movie definitely
gives you its [ __ ] money's worth
um there's a lot of movie there to
decipher to enjoy
um all of it very batman like all of it
um very in keeping with uh how the
character's been treated by other
writers very denny o'neill um like in
moments
um in telling its kind of year two-ish
story um even the appearance of what i
think
was venom
juice yeah at one point he's like down
for the count and all of a sudden he
[ __ ]
puts this [ __ ] in his arm or whatever
and i turned to
mark and i was like adrenaline and ralph
goes venom [ __ ] and i was like oh [ __ ]
so they're setting up for [ __ ] down the
road for you know venom is the [ __ ] that
made bane what bane became
um so you know and and of course the
the man in the cell who chit chats with
the riddler
um you know hints and indicates that the
world yet to come
and that world is playing it pretty damn
straight playing it pretty real
um
i like it i like it look it's better
than any [ __ ] batman movie i could
ever make and i don't really have like
uh this is what would make it better
like you're very good at that sort of
thing um you know but
this is not
i don't want [ __ ] the internet to
come after me and [ __ ] but as a as it
i'm not saying i'm a great editor but as
a film editor
for me i was just like
we can lose that we can lose that we can
lose that and
make it more efficient more screenings
but whatever the [ __ ] it made all the
money in the world so it's not like it
needed help doing that
that's just my little pet peeve i don't
like long movies fair
i mean i for me it's
i'm glad it exists because i hope
that if batman and robin was the end of
one spectrum then maybe this movie's the
end of another spectrum
and for me
i think batman is at its best when it's
somewhere in the middle it's not quite
as goofy nothing should be as goofy as
that yeah but but i i just need a little
more fantasy in my superhero content i
don't actually need it to be that real
and so
i i think there's a happy medium
somewhere that nobody's actually quite
cracked yet
but i think that like hopefully
for me this is the end of this road
of there was that meme that went around
it's like it's 1989 and i'm 14 years old
and i'm getting grittier darker batman
it's
2005 and i'm 25 years old and i'm
getting a grittier darker batman
it's 2022
and i'm 40 years old i'm getting a
grittier darker batman
we just keep
pushing this dial to a place where again
he's just a [ __ ] guy
he's not the smartest he's not the best
he's not there's nothing special about
this guy
not even will per se because that never
seems to be brought to bear other than
i'm happy to get shot a lot because
dodging was the thing that
[ __ ]
alfred taught me
yeah you [ __ ] get shot like point
blank in the chest at one point like a
lot yeah
and they don't i mean i got we're just
taking it for granted that it's just
bulletproof plating and stuff
they never say you know he doesn't feel
the need like chris nolan to obsessively
explain how everything could be a real
thing right like you know he was always
like see this [ __ ] this does this
because that's what would happen in the
real [ __ ] world [ __ ] like [ __ ]
but this one they just
didn't necessarily feel the need to
explain their science i am so [ __ ]
happy
that pearls never made an appearance in
this movie yeah
like and we've talked about it before
but like i don't need that origin story
ever again no the same way we no longer
need spider-man's origin story like i
get it
this they did they tweaked the origin
story though they this time around they
hinted the fact hint they flat out say
that his mother was uh in asylums when
she mother's an arkham martha his mother
a is an arkham and then b that she was
in
in and out of sanitariums like when she
was younger right which
you know i guess could point like to
like well she you know passed on
something to her kid because he's
obviously very committed as well
um
it's uh
that's a new wrinkle what do you think
that was all about
i mean i think it's it's it's trying to
do that thing where unifies the theories
the unified theory of batman and of
gotham city which is especially the
waynes are in some ways the the patron
saints of gotham but also
the the agents of destruction of gotham
where like if thomas wayne built arkham
asylum
ultimately for
his wife
and then it goes wrong
like that's [ __ ] up
is it they didn't say that though did
that i think they do i think they
intimate that like arkham son doesn't
exist until thomas wayne builds it
because he's like because but they don't
say he built it for his wife that'd be
[ __ ] so metal i think inspired by his
wife and like his wife's experience in
in institutions like i'm gonna build the
best one ever and call him arkham asylum
after my wife
after her mate and then it just goes
[ __ ] south south when he dies
and whatever that was was that in the
movie or that's your take
um that's a bit of my take but they do
mention that he built
arkham asylum i like your take
thanks
um it is uh
let's see pattinson uh does a great job
but i can't wait to see him
create a bruce wayne who's like uh
completely different than batman the
mask once he puts on the hopefully the
next boot there's going to be another
movie for sure
this one did a little bit of business so
they're gonna do another one so uh
hopefully there we'll see
him bust out a [ __ ] cheeky bruce
wayne um
i thought zoey kravitz was great i
thought colin farrell was
wonderful i don't know how you arrive at
that how do you go like let's take a
dude who's like
thin as a [ __ ] toothpick and and make
him the penguin like
but it worked so [ __ ] good man
um
uh paul dano didn't really have that
much to do
no
no
he was very kind of boring a little flat
never never went for it
the uh sarcasm
the um
yeah it's he he i mean he does exactly
what he needs to do
um
what's his name who played alfred
andy circus a continued [ __ ] treasure
man like this dude is [ __ ] good in
everything like and and believable and
he could be heartwarming yet still
[ __ ] stern and [ __ ] i i would have
liked more
alfred in this and
less incivility toward alfred
really bummed me out that bruce was
always just like [ __ ] you alfred
it's like that's your [ __ ] debt
you're not my dad he even says that you
know my father alfred it's like come on
dude but he kind of is i'm taking the
keys i'm going for a ride
and you know that moment
which was almost amazing when they
introduced the batmobile you know and i
was like i'll follow them gordon don't
worry about it and then you hear the
engines roar and the whine of the engine
the [ __ ] turbine and the blue light
starts to flash
look at that [ __ ] and then it like
and it like stalls because he pops the
clutch and he can't get into gear right
i'm like is that what happened
the car does this like little jump and
then it doesn't do anything i thought it
was just him being like [ __ ]
like that kind of thing like [ __ ] yeah
like you feeling froggy come on jump
yeah like you flinch [ __ ]
flinch that kind of which is weird to do
in a car though
um i just thought it was like you know
the [ __ ] 26 angles of
and everyone's like
nobody [ __ ] moves for 20 seconds
while this car revs its engine and [ __ ]
but that's a movie that's a movie um
have we have we rendered a take on the
batman
yeah i think so and hopefully people
hopefully what communicates is
i liked it
i did i liked it it's better than any
batman movie i could ever make and stuff
but here's what i'll say
i think of this very much like batman
begins this feels i'm not saying it's
the exact same movie but it had the same
i had the same take on it when i saw
batman begins i was like oh [ __ ] that's
clever
um well done but i wasn't like oh my god
this is my religion until it became the
dark knight so i look forward to what he
does next i think his next batman movie
will absolutely [ __ ] steal my head
and heart if it follows
like you know batman begins to to the
dark knight and i think that's
absolutely possible
um so i like this but i bet y'all love
the next one
okay
what's your final summation uh mr e
former ew didn't you guys used to have
to pivotally
[ __ ] sum [ __ ] up in a black sentence
like a darker sentence yeah like i
appreciate the ambition because they
were really going for a thing and i
appreciate the choices this is not a
movie that was afraid to make real hard
choices on things
and that's always hard to do when
dealing in a giant studio atmosphere
where they would rather things be a
little nebulous and like that's not
let's not decide there's no wayne manor
there's a wayne tower
let's not decide that there's no mansion
somewhere that he [ __ ] lives in the
middle of gotham like that's kind of
cool makes sense this movie makes lots
of choices especially about the mythos
that are interesting the
martha's a wayne not just another member
of gotham society but i mean
arkham yeah like that's an innovation on
on the previously existing canon
the lenses and this contact lenses which
i [ __ ] love which shoot everything
yeah record everything
you know i think there's there's some
really interesting decisions on the
margins
but i think that that going forward
and hopefully that to your point it's
batman begins that will lead to a thing
that's richer and deeper and more
emotionally resident um and that gives
this batman and this bruce wayne a bit
more to do
because again the riddler would have
done all the things that the riddler had
done if batman was not there and i don't
necessarily need my batman to be an
ineffectual hero he needs to do a thing
and catwoman by the way gets the guy who
gives them
all of the information i'm gonna go get
that dude who i think might have killed
my mom and then she brings him to that
tower and she's getting a confession out
of him as bruce is like maybe don't
shoot him
that's kind of all he does in that scene
she solves the crime
she knows who did it she knows why
it's like i kind of need more from
the titular character of my movie to not
just be a bystander in his own adventure
i hadn't thought of that i guess you're
right and in terms of she does [ __ ]
get to the bottom of things he's the
indiana jones
of the batman explain that reference for
those who don't know
uh if you will track the events of
raiders of the lost ark you will
discover
that henry jones jr
does nothing to stop the nazis from
getting what they want
because what they want to do is take the
ark to this island open it up and then
prove that there's magic in there to
show it to hitler and so if indiana
jones never showed up to that movie they
would have done the very same thing it
would have taken them longer to get
there they might have just put it on a
plane and it would have been like 20
minutes long he's a piece of speed bump
on their road to getting what they think
they want
and it's fine because we love indiana
jones it's fine because it's a [ __ ]
romp and it's an adventure and the
character's amazing
but he doesn't actually bear that much
impact on the bad guy's plan
and i think that bruce wayne slash
batman in this movie is very much the
same which is
the riddler wins
he gets exactly what he wants to get he
does exactly what he wants to do except
for maybe we're gonna kill the mayor
which he doesn't get to pull off which
feels like an afterthought anyway
um i was also glad they
they teased the whole like um bruce
wayne and i'm like not another
[ __ ] who knows who this
[ __ ] is
like come on man like that's i didn't
like that about lex luthor and batman v
superman knew everybody's secret
identity i'm like come on that sucks
so they hinted at that and then he
[ __ ] pulls back from it and i was
like oh thank god
um i i prefer my batman to have a secret
identity even though like it just takes
some cognitive thought to be like who
could afford all this
oh the mopey millionaire sounds exactly
like batman maybe it's him also look at
his face i can see most of it yeah if
you do this oh it's [ __ ] him
um
how do you think kids play batman these
days
like do they have action figures for
this movie
i would love to see the kids commercial
with these i remember like the star wars
commercials where they're like oh man
we're doing the adventure on vengeance
new i'm vengeance yeah
we're both vengeance
pray to me you're right timmy pray to
you
you may not see the pearls but i'm real
sad my parents died
it's just like when we were kids you
could have a batman action figure and
play [ __ ] these movies i think have made
it progressively harder
for a kid to pick up a batman toy and
feel anything but [ __ ] empathy and
sorrow
who is your batman he throws him against
the wall he's like he's squirrel suit
batman who's not good at it yet
live the adventure
um yeah man it's uh well it's out there
kids go see the batman if you haven't
already man it's definitely worth seeing
if you're looking for a batman movie
[ __ ] they got three hours of one for you
and somehow we didn't also tell you
everything that happens in it yeah we
missed a lot of stuff i'm sure hey banff
man what's the
chat looking like are we dead meat or
what
you're not
oh are you dead they killed your mic
they won't like i did i killed my mic um
people
people don't like mark's take
imagine that is the easiest way to say
it uh
the only thing they said about you is
kevin is a filthy line cutter because
you budged to see batman 89
because i what you budged to the line to
see batman 89
oh my god
is that why i'm gonna be canceled this
week they're like this piece of [ __ ] cut
the line in 89.
can't [ __ ] win
nope
um i'll take that yeah i did my friends
held a place in line for me and i'm so
[ __ ] glad the chat seems to have
loved the movie yeah everybody loves
this [ __ ] movie not everybody
that's okay
most people always seem to dig it um you
haven't seen it yet though huh i haven't
seen it
it might
i still don't know what happened
i'm reading about how the chat says you
guys are wrong so i'm i'm just i'm wrong
well you're wrong i'm wrong you're
factually about
about opinions or factually about them
no just that you have bad opinions oh
yeah i i again it's not you it's not an
imperial we
it is just me that's almost the subtitle
of the show man is fat man beyond colin
mark has bad opinions
like i'm not sure i like that guy
that's okay but if you do like i
honestly didn't hear a negative review
from you as much though as like it just
sounds like the way you talk about
everything which is like this is what i
liked this is what i didn't like here's
a [ __ ] that should have made better
moving on like i didn't i didn't get you
going catch negative you didn't catch me
being like i didn't like this movie no
not as not as negative that's not my
like if i was at rotten tomatoes and i
had to give you a a [ __ ] splatted
tomato or a [ __ ] fresh tomato for you
for your review out in the world i would
i would give your review a fresh tomato
that'd be wrong
i'm trying to [ __ ] help you here
i didn't i didn't hate this movie i i
think it's a deeply flawed film
that that only has those flaws because
of ambition i don't think it's a lazy
movie no it's not everybody
is like working at
top speed everybody is flawless in the
execution of their [ __ ] jobs it looks
fantastic
the acting is fantastic [ __ ] the
script is serious as [ __ ] like
top-notch across the boards i don't
think anybody's saying that's not the
factor no but at this point in our
relationship audience
you know what you came for
i'm sorry i don't know what to tell you
um i wanted i want every movie i ever
see to be great
um and then the the the mission for me
is to find out again for me why it isn't
you know what you could have done to
help tell the story it wants to tell a
little bit better and i try not to do
that too much because i like to take
movies for what they are
and try and figure out what its
intentions were
but the writer in me sometimes can't
help just trying to nudge it along its
path but
hey if you loved it i'm so glad you
loved it because the world needs ways
for you to find joy and if this is one
of those ways
go for it love it to pieces tell
everybody you've ever met you should go
see the batman because that way we get
more batman movies and then maybe for me
we'll find one that hits the sweet spot
but but if you're finding joy in the
batman
seek a therapist because
there are other things that will put a
smile on your face
um not to say that batman's the batman's
depressing it's just
it's pretty depressing it's
pretty [ __ ] somber i mean the amount
of fighting this guy does with alfred
really made me [ __ ] blue
he's your only tether to the real world
made me want to call my mother and be
like i'm so sorry i was ever an [ __ ]
to you or something
um yeah go check out the batman kids
i'll tell you we just got the [ __ ]
single greatest incarnation of the
batman ever in the [ __ ] trailer for
the league of super pets
have you seen the trailer yet keanu
reeves piano batman oh my god where he's
like you are a dog
i am the batman
oh i [ __ ] loved it so much that movie
looks [ __ ] good that wasn't even
really on my radar i was like ugh super
pets but that trailer is charming past
the rock as crypto i was like huh yeah
this feels weird and then the trailer
started i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
and then it's oh [ __ ] it's that part oh
cool
i look forward to that looks [ __ ]
legit good to me i mean what was he in
toy story for was he duke kaboom yeah
i'm here for keanu reeves doing like
really weird voices that are perfect for
gannon reeves to do and kevin hart has
aced the bat hound like there's a moment
in the trailer where he's where batman
just like
uh when i was a child um are you
[ __ ] trying to kill me
he goes i gotta drive home at some point
they're like keep talking about the
batman mark
chat paid us they venmo us money to get
you wasted
um he goes uh the bat batman goes like
uh
when uh when he goes when i was a child
my family was taken from me and then
they got to [ __ ] ace the bat around
he goes when i was a puppy i was taken
from my family
so [ __ ] good i look forward to
watching that
um all right
done with the batman done with the
batman do we have news to talk about
this week we got one more ad we gotta do
and then news and then news
well okay should we do the news and then
do the ad and then do the q a i know one
person will be very unhappy if we do
that then let's do what that person
wants
um who's our second sponsor of the
evening ladies and gentlemen our second
sponsor the good folks at keeps keeps
giving up for the good folks it keeps
man
all they're interested in doing is
making you keep your hair that's it they
just want you keep it they put it right
there in their name they don't bury the
[ __ ] leader no keeps k eps go to what
is the website k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
fat man to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com
fat man to get your first month free
kids don't
be wed to a [ __ ] backwards baseball
cap for the rest of your life
you use keeps and you'll keep your
[ __ ] hair and you [ __ ] look at
people in baseball caps and be like i
know what you're hiding under there you
piece of [ __ ]
keeps is gonna let you keep what you got
i wish this [ __ ] existed when i was a
youngster oh i [ __ ] wish it existed
but it doesn't but all good things come
too late man it does more than 50
million men in the u.s suffer from male
pattern baldness that's two out of three
guys will experience some form of hair
loss by the time they're thirty one two
where's the third guy
jc he's got a whole [ __ ] head of hair
[ __ ] like it's pete mitchell style
hair right there
look at it just
i can't i got to stop is that a top gun
reference yeah it is baby
to the danger zone with you and your
head
keeps over is a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your hair via
convenient virtual doctors consultations
and medications delivered through the
mail every three months 24 7 care and
support and a low cost treatments start
at 10 per month and keeps offers generic
versions of the two fda approved
medications to prevent hair loss
so if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keps.com fat man
or use the code fat man at checkout to
get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com fat man we must have a
[ __ ] hair thinning audience ladies
and gentlemen because the good folks at
keeps have been with us for years now
years so you must be feeding the kitty
over there so thank you all of you who
have ordered keeps man and we thank the
good folks keeps for sponsoring fat man
beyond giving up for keeps yes
sun news um okay what's the news uh
we're gonna go bat heavy on this news
okay i wanted to be on on theme
um batman opened to over 134 million
dollars domestic oh they made a bunch of
money that's got to be one of the best
openings of the pandemic era um i
believe it is i believe it barely beat
spider-man no way home
it what no it didn't beat [ __ ]
spider-man it was the biggest opening of
the pandemic er
hold
it's coming through now
spider-man no way home opened with
128.5 million the batman opened at 134
million
oh my god man batman beat up spider-man
i know go home spider-man oh you don't
know how to get there i'll help you
there's no way
um wow man [ __ ] do you think but
there's no way it outgrosses spiderman
no way home do you think um it's unclear
you know it's a it's a 258 million
worldwide after its first weekend
it just needs to keep pace and there's
not much that's in the way of it um not
much competition really until [ __ ]
doctor strange two opens up when's that
um
may
um
so wow so they got two months free and
clear they got a lot of runway
more beasts i mean morbius
sure
nate you're adorable
people like i'm turning my back on
[ __ ] battinson because i'm getting
ready for morbids
yeah true it's the secrets of dumbledore
dumbledore's coming is that is anybody
excited about that
no
some folks are there are people i've not
uh caught up with those fantastic beasts
movies yeah i i saw but this one's very
close to like they take you to hogwarts
right so it's like this is the first one
that's
super harry pottery it seems to be very
much about dumbledore which my question
was always if you told me that it was
going to be hot gabe young dumbledore
why all these movies weren't [ __ ]
about hot young gay dumbledore yeah he's
like you want to see me make some magic
yeah
expectopacronum
i don't even know what that means
um that i guess that's a big flick that
people are looking forward to as well
yeah um kind of bias right we always
talk about superhero movies but that's
kind of a superhero movie
the harry potter you know he is a
superhero of sorts he's got a tragic
[ __ ] childhood much like batman he's
the boy who lived exactly
um but yeah i'm not lining up to see
that floyd you're not that dude
no and not because i'm like it sucks i
just they didn't capture my imagination
with the
fantastic beast movies
like they kept me all throughout the
potters man because i used to read those
books when the kid was little
but then when they did this thing i was
like
yeah but um so yeah it looks like the
batman will continue to earn for quite
some time it will um hopefully in the 45
days before it shows up on hbo max is
that when it's coming
i think that's the new window it's 45
days i'm not sure if they're gonna
adjust it if this movie continues to do
like crazy [ __ ] business but that's
what they said
that's what the people said i look
forward to watching it i'll watch it a
bunch will you
i will i watched batman v superman so
many times over and over because i was
like one day i'm gonna love this movie
and i i did i just kept watching it and
watching and watching it
so i think i'm gonna do the same with
the batman i'll watch it obsessively and
[ __ ] like when i got nothing going on
i'll just pop that on it has like one of
the best openings of a batman movie ever
just says the batman and they're playing
classical music or ave maria or
something like that
and it doesn't even begin with him
like it's not even like batman's pov you
start with the with the riddler um
spoilers i mean the whole [ __ ] thing
is spoilers
yeah one way to come into the end with
the spoilers
i'll you know honestly i'll watch like
the first two hours over and over again
and that's not to say that the last hour
the last 45 minutes sucks or something
like that not at all but
it it it does feel like a bifurcated
movie it feels like
two-thirds of it is is a detective noir
thriller and then the last third is a
superhero movie from comes out of
nowhere and stuff
um and i i like the the noir i like the
detective thing i thought that was
really original and brand new and stuff
um him taking on a like [ __ ]
city-wide threat
we've seen that like a bunch before so i
imagine i'll re-watch the first two
hours like over and over and over again
and again not where i'm like oh it's
this the flood [ __ ] them it's just
that's when i'll probably be less
interested and then if it follows batman
v superman i'll start watching just the
flood hour over and over again so that i
fall in love with that
i devote a lot of time to batman movies
mark
yeah
yeah you do that's why we're here if
they don't steal my heart i'll make them
steal my heart
i'll find a way to love you yet yes um
in other baton news zoe kravitz did an
interview with the observer and revealed
that she tried to audition for a role in
the dark knight rises
um specifically the role that juno
temple ended up getting as a friend oh
who was the buddy the buddy right the
buddy of cement kyle
and was told that she was rejected after
she told she was too urban for the part
oh [ __ ] meaning she lives in los angeles
yeah no she's a city dweller wow [ __ ]
how many years ago was that
um what the [ __ ] is dark knight rises
that would have been 2012
20 15 20 so it's not even like oh that
was the 50s it was a different time then
no no it's a 21st century yeah um i
don't know if it came directly from
chris nolan kravitz said i think there's
probably a casting director of some kind
or a casting director's assistant but
being a woman of color and being an
actor and being told at the time that i
wasn't able to read because of the color
of my skin and the word urban being
thrown around like that that was what
was really hard in the moment
um that would suck yeah in a 2015
interview with nylon what would not suck
though is when they're like now you're
playing catwoman
and then i'd be like i can't wait to
tell that story yeah that's the only
thing
which is you can't take it away from me
now yeah really i've already done it and
i've got my own tv show you're gonna be
sitting bloodhaven it all [ __ ] wins
for me what
they're making a catwoman tv show on the
hbo maxis did you guys not know this
i didn't hear that
oh my stars and garters
where'd you hear this
it broke a while ago man is that right
yeah
but but hey it's news to you that's cool
uh glad i did a thing let's get our fact
checker nate pull out a phone and see if
there's talk of a zoey kravitz catwoman
show or if mark had a fever-pitched
dream of some sort
i'd heard of the gotham police show
which now matt reeves is saying is being
put on hold
because i guess they're thinking about
an arkham show
that is my next news item is it so
that's real yeah oh [ __ ] um is there
anything about a catwoman
hbo max show
yeah i hadn't heard anything about that
because that would have been big news
penguin's getting his own show we've
heard that
says they're working on three
three shows three shows arkham catwoman
and penguin and wow this is
you got somebody backing you up on
catwoman see i'll take that arkham show
i think that's a cool idea
the idea of like they could use the show
to develop villains that maybe are
lesser [ __ ] villains that could pop
up in the future the batman movies or
whatever they call the batman sequel
i like that i love that we're in a world
now where it's like we have a
possibility of watching a streaming
arkham show where every week they're
like oh let's do the [ __ ] secret
origin of one of these crazy villains
from the rogues gallery it's like a
great time to be alive
why would you choose two villains from
the tv show
they have so many [ __ ] comic book
villains to choose from um but yes like
to skip to the next item uh matt reeves
has been clearly doing press for his
little batman picture
um and he said that the the seems like a
nice guy
he does
the gotham police department show has
evolved into a series focus on arkham
asylum he compared it to a horror movie
or haunted house story um the spin-off
which had never been officially named
was announced in 2020 when and was set
to focus on jim gordon
and it was supposed to take inspiration
from the movie prince of the city
centering on a cop who's battling for
his soul he was reawakened by a rising
gotham city vigilante
uh the batman
but he did say that the
gcpd thing has sort of shifted and
they're now moving more into the realm
of exactly what would happen in the
world of arkham as relates to the coming
off of our movie and some of the
characters again in their origins it's
like a horror movie haunted house i'll
take that i i would rather watch that
than a gotham
central tv show or gotham pd tv show
[ __ ] arkham asylum
and they give us like [ __ ] rogues
gallery origins every episode or every
other episode
that's how i think about that
highest review we can give on batman
beyond
coming in one's own face and then eating
it
but my takes are the ones you don't like
fair enough
uh moving off of the catwoman show why
would she do that she don't need that
she's gonna be [ __ ] she's already a
famous movie star but now she can be
even more so
but then again she did have that high
fidelity show and she was mad when they
canceled that show
she's still talking about superman yeah
she's been using the batman tour to
grind some axes about that too
going like you know i still think they
shouldn't have canceled [ __ ] high
fidelity yeah this is this is zoe's
power hour where's like you know what
let me tell you some [ __ ] she was good
in it i bet you she could probably get
that show back on
now with this being such a huge success
totally
um right i bet you
i'd like to see you try uh but her in a
catwoman show
i don't know i don't i don't i mean i
totally watch it because it's on hbo max
and i already get it and it's free
but i'm not i'm not chomping at the bit
for that one
and not because i don't like her it's
just like i don't know a whole catwoman
show
what if it's scarecrow mrs king but a
scarecrow misses kyle oh my god i want
to watch that show
you can't have it because my takes suck
um all right what else we got
hopping off of batman for a second it
broke this past week that disney plus
is adding all of the marvel netflix
shows oh [ __ ] look at that so now
they're real live uh [ __ ] boys like
pinocchio indeed so daredevil jessica
jones luke cage iron fist the punisher
and the defenders as well as agents of
shield
are all now going to be on disney plus
now agents of shield i don't bump into
it all because disney plus seems to be
very family friendly but
some of those marvel netflix shows were
awfully grown upy you know they're all
tvna
which means your ma has to tell you you
can watch it is that right have they
ever done that on disney pollution they
never have wow
breaking some new ground which is you
know if i had to guess it's part of an
experiment to see like can the audience
handle it right so wait they own logan
yes does logan play on disney plus it
currently doesn't it doesn't because
it's r rated
i think it's on hulu
but they don't have anything r-rated on
disney plus no
this could change that
this could be the slippery slope or the
like slippery slope first we let in the
marvel netflix shows next we did full
frontal male nudity suddenly it's donald
going
mickey
um
good i'm glad they're there that means
we're one step closer to [ __ ] the
return of charlie cox's daredevil yeah
and i think it also is helping to tee up
because i think moon night is a little
bit oh my god
[ __ ] does that show look amazing
jesus if that show don't cure cancer i'm
gonna be disappointed as hell
because it looks [ __ ] so fantastic
man i'm ready to commit my life to
khanshu this [ __ ] show looks
phenomenal
uh two quick hits okay two shows that
were announced when does that begin that
[ __ ] moon night to moon night all
right hold on march right it's coming
soon i think it's march the end of this
month
just have to live a little longer just a
little bit longer
how many episodes does it everybody know
six
six six i'm all for it man keep it tight
like [ __ ] i want to get in and get
out
satisfy me i want to come and leave
that's it i don't want to [ __ ] sit
around and chit chat and whatnot i got
[ __ ] to do
you're the bruce wayne of this aren't
you
um six episodes that sounds [ __ ] good
yeah i'm in um so two quick things about
two shows that are now in development
there's a new walking dead spin-off
which is heading to manhattan with
maggie and negan called isle of the dead
are you [ __ ] me it's gonna take
place in new york yeah
that you know what like that actually
got me excited that's the one i mean
yeah like because when you were like oh
another walking dead show i was like
this [ __ ] thing's still happening but
when you were like they go to new york
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm in
i've been to new york zombies take
manhattan yeah
um that's a new wrinkle i'll check that
out and there's a new
muppet show
coming to disney plus god they [ __ ]
try this every three years they do but
this one though oh i might know about
this one i'm here for this one you will
probably know about it adam goldberg
show focus on the electric mayhem yes
adam goldberg of the goldbergs is doing
a muppet show that is focused on a
doctor teeth and the electric mayhem
it's it's
mostly the [ __ ] band yeah the series
will follow the electric mayhem band as
they go on an epic musical journey to
finally record their first studio album
that's a that's a clever [ __ ] concept
i'm here for it
i love adam he's good uh i believe in
that that's going to be a good show
um
i love the band the band was always
great
i got that girl who's like hey man janet
yes
and animals
is that the end of the news that's the
end of the news ladies and gentlemen
mark benarden gave you the news give it
up for mark bernardin
[Applause]
um okay we reached the part of the show
that uh involves you the audience ladies
and gentlemen uh you wrote down some
[ __ ] questions you gave them to
jc and uh
uh jc
um has picked a few before we jump there
though uh one of these cards that was up
here with all the stuff that we signed
says could you give a shout out to the
los angeles mission i work for this
homeless shelter
in skid row uh we would also like to
invite you to come visit any time
um it's at the la mission
on instagram um who wrote this
you did look at you doing the lord's
work man like that's
we sit up here and argue about whether
[ __ ] rob pattinson is a good batman
and you're [ __ ] being batman down in
the streets well done the la mission how
can people help out
donations or anything
come volunteer
um yeah uh come to the la mission come
volunteer
um come and what does one do when one
volunteers like what um you can come
serve and i don't like to clean toilets
is that a thing because i don't do that
at my own phone
you want to come clean toilets you can
come clean no i don't want to do that
like you can come well do you need
somebody to come podcast for like three
hours we have a podcast with our ceo we
actually have we have one of the few
ceos in los angeles that has lived
experience of homelessness in la r for
ceo who's african-american
who has a lived experience of
homelessness he is heading our our
organization we have an easter event
coming up and we're also doing a race to
feed campaign we're inviting anybody to
come if you're a cook or anything to
come sponsor meals to come out into the
community
also i'm actually going to south by
southwest
next week
to come support and show what we can do
about bringing technology and culture
into the non-profit sector so
but but even if you're not doing it at
the la mission
either even if it's a grassroots
organization anything that you're doing
to support the homeless services
community
my friend and i steve's birthday was
last week he works in homelessness
you've got the [ __ ] record player
last week yes you've got the record
player last week
[Laughter]
steve steven silva uh we we both work in
the homeless services sector and really
just anything you can do to support your
for our friends and neighbors whether
they're in skid row in la
would love to talk to you about it
thanks for signing my id last time by
the way no worries let's hope that let's
let's hope they take that on the airline
so yeah really um i would uh i like to
help so get me some info man i will i
will get you after the show if you have
some time sweet
sweet thank you give it up for what's
your name
i'm monique
uh-oh does he need avocado
i missed it because the mic went out
monique who monique
give it up for monique everybody she's
doing a goddamn lord's work
[Applause]
um okay yeah quick question whoever put
this up am i signing one book to two
daughters or am i signing both books one
to each daughter
one book two daughters done thank you
thank you
um all right jc
you picked some questions i did
first off uh the chat is letting me know
that what do we do wrong no uh
in canada disney plus is airing pam and
tommy
right
because they have star overseas which is
a section of disney plus like hulu is
here that lets them do more mature
content so i go to canada yeah i watch
disney plus i could see a talking dick
yeah that
they wanted us to know that
i have been watching the [ __ ] out of pam
tommy's wonderful
but hulu just started another uh series
uh last week
with amanda seyfried called the dropout
which is the elizabeth holmes story the
thrano story and it is so [ __ ] good
she's
even though i think that real elizabeth
holmes is like [ __ ] 10 feet taller
than amanda she is playing the [ __ ] out
of that part so much so that you're like
no she's tall as [ __ ]
um
pretty impressive performance and not
like she's not buried in latex to do it
which takes nothing away from [ __ ]
lily james who deserves a [ __ ] emmy
for her performance as pamela anderson
and you know granted she's got a lot of
prosthetic enhancement but that
performance is so incredibly winning i
hope she wins a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
not like that [ __ ] matters but actors
seem to like that kind of [ __ ]
they're like awards like prizes
uh yeah i binged that last night which
one um
pam and tommy or no uh dropping out it's
good right yeah doesn't piss you off
though when you get to like the third
episode and you're like i want the next
one and they're like come back in a week
it does
remember how tv used to be i know i know
man but i'm [ __ ] this first taste is
free [ __ ] really irritates me
sometimes you just want to [ __ ] binge
man just be like ah
anyway
all right we got questions we do uh and
actually monique is our first question
so oh [ __ ] so people are actually gonna
get to see monique
um as opposed to just hear her voice uh
give it up for monique she's first man
[Applause]
okay um so
it's uh it's international you're
wearing the [ __ ] out of that scarf well
done man i'm slytherin harry potter hey
yeah
homeless services community in l.a
so it's international women's day today
it is my wife told me that right before
i left the house she's like don't forget
it's international women's it is and my
nerd question is
who has the stupidest outfit and hair
amongst women characters in your
favorite geekdoms that compromise their
superpowers or work so whose hair and
outfits undermine their badassery
um you know i have an answer for this
because only because i've been thinking
about my whole life
[Laughter]
i've been waiting my whole life finally
i get to say this i love
the look of batgirl
everything about the look of the
character from its original incarnation
even up to the current incarnation we've
seen images of the
the forthcoming batgirl hbo max movie
um i love the character i love the look
of the character i wouldn't change a
[ __ ] thing
however
in the real world
there is no reason
no good reason
to put hair
onto a cowl
that just gives a villain one more
[ __ ] thing to grab and swing you
around you're already wearing a cape
which is easily [ __ ] grabbable but
then to put [ __ ] hair like if it's
one thing if it's your hair and you're
like i ain't cutting this [ __ ] not even
for crime like all right you got to deal
with that but you're putting on a
[ __ ] fake wig
like to what throw people off the scent
that you're a librarian so like
batgirl's hair is always as much as i
love the look of it um i i just i think
it's not functional or it doesn't make
sense whatsoever i'll buy everything
about batgirl except that hair man
you
uh i
maybe it's because i spent actual money
to go see the inhumans
in imax oh [ __ ]
like literal [ __ ] dollars
and like not cheap dollars these imax
[ __ ] imax dollars yeah matinee was
like 15 bucks
you see that piece of [ __ ] and
oh my god you lost the other half of
chat now sorry guys for like the eight
people who thought that in humans was
great
note that that was not on one of those
series they're bringing to [ __ ]
disney plus they much rather is that
right yeah they're never gonna admit
they made that thing so
medusa's hair is stupid
in that in that movie in that movie like
i think there's probably in comics it
works pure naturally like agile hair uh
prehensile hair she can use it to
picture that and pre-natural and
pronounced feet are natural natural um
either one of those pre-words um i'm
sorry man i'm too [ __ ] wakanda's in i
see your [ __ ]
your empty drinks because
not what kind of forever wakanda two
drinks that's it we can't do this
forever
wakanda i have a limit
did you know that the wakanda greeting
is actually based on a yerubin actual
greeting that is used this
i did yeah in aruba culture this is
actually used as a greeting
what kind of person you think i am
then i'm gonna keep drinking wakanda
forevers
the right kind of person
but but can you take that black widow
no no i can't it's too much for me um
but i think and it's general geekdom
right it's not specifically superheroes
i never bought that rapunzel's [ __ ]
hair follicles were so goddamn strong
that you could hoist the person up by
her hair
that never made no kind of sense to me
and granted maybe it's magic hair but
it's the same kind of like i got a
bionic arm do you have a bionic spine
because otherwise your arm is going to
rip off if you try to lift that car son
i don't know what you're doing oh my god
i [ __ ]
when i wrote years ago when i wrote the
bionic man screenplay six million dollar
man
and then uh uh the dynamite turned into
a comic book years later but i wrote
like in the original in the book cyborg
and in the tv show the six million
dollar man it was based on the book
cyborg
you know he loses his legs in one of his
arms
um and so they give him two bionic legs
and give them one bionic arm but like in
in my version i was like well
we saved
you you lost one of your arms but in
order for us to balance out the bionics
we had to take the good arm and replace
it and so he was even more outraged by
that sort of [ __ ] but it was about
balance it was about like you know just
the the engineering of like putting
like this thing that could lift 4 000
pounds onto one side
of the body now i wrote that in 1996
and i'm so glad that 26 years later
you confirmed the science for me man
like
like you could squeeze some [ __ ] with a
bionic hand but you couldn't do this
[ __ ] without [ __ ]
yes suddenly your spine collapses
because that's not bionic that's just a
spine yeah and like i i breathe deep
when i'm getting up these days and
like i just that doesn't work so yeah
let me tell you about rapunzel too man
like [ __ ] i'll tell you some [ __ ]
about
that sh she should have used that hair
as a [ __ ] test because any man that
was like yeah i'll crawl up your hair
is no man worth her [ __ ] time
as soon as she they were like rapunzel
let down your hair be like [ __ ] you and
yeah get [ __ ] up and then you [ __ ]
get with the guy who's like i figured
[ __ ] out wiley coyote style
to get up there yeah not using it
shouldn't be that [ __ ] easy like now
but if it's like michelle yo style where
she's whipping that air around like it's
got a spear at the end of it here for it
but the the base of that scalp should
not be holding up an actual man person
no
any number of hustler cartoons would
tell you that it was pubic hair
and that would be even [ __ ] harder to
climb up i'll tell you what yeah little
annie fanny had it going
um all right [ __ ] rapunzel happy
international women's day
i guess
are you happy with that monique
oh i'm so happy do we have any prizes
we do
uh 40x behind you we have posters and
40x and 40x tickets yeah we forgot the
parade of prizes uh ladies and gentlemen
uh for those who get to ask a question
tonight they're gonna walk away with
this gorgeous
nate gonzalez prince look at that [ __ ]
man
featuring uh fat man beyond himself and
uh mark as uh jim gordon
uh and you're also gonna get two tickets
to 40x man which i wholeheartedly
recommend you use to go see
uh the batman uh bring soap because
you're gonna get wet in the shower so
you can get two things done at once
we thank you very [ __ ] native well
done [ __ ] well done
support native we thank the good folks
at 4dx and uh brett deacon for getting
us these tickets and this poster and
this ticket go to monique give it up for
modique
[Applause]
got it right right over left
all right captain uh roy warren
boy
[Applause]
uh are you like john walker
like
there's some real like captain america
but like
trying to make you blush mark you got
some vibes going i'm just saying
um what film character that you used to
loathe have you come to respect or
relate to as you've gotten older
wow what a great question
that is a great question as your buddies
like that is a great question you're
[ __ ] right he's my [ __ ]
friend it but jerry made me do it
nice job jerry well done jerry what film
character although
we're not a bank jerry um
let's see
who did i [ __ ] hate
and then i grew up to like
i'm not sure i can go as far as like
okay but understand okay
i for a very very long time
hated carter j burke from aliens
paul ryan yeah
he uh
he presents in the movie as an [ __ ]
right like he's the guy who [ __ ] over
like you don't see them [ __ ]
themselves over for a goddamn percentage
like he's the one who puts the [ __ ]
you know the the face hugger in the
middle of of newt and ripley's cabin
he's the one trying to smuggle these
things back he's the one who wants to
bring it back for robin's research and
you know ripley and crew were like we
gotta nick decide for more but the only
way to be sure but here's just a dude
trying to [ __ ] do what his bosses
tell him to do
here's a guy who's just like middle
management he's probably got a wife that
he doesn't really love but a daughter
that he loves to death he's like i just
want to be able to get my bonus at the
end of the year buy her a [ __ ] pony
and everybody wins like i'm just a guy
trying to make it work
and here's these [ __ ] space marines
and their weird-ass pseudo-boss
just [ __ ] my [ __ ] up like i
nobody's gonna get hurt except these
people that's no no you don't see you
don't see the aliens [ __ ] each over
for a percentage mark i'm just saying i
understand why he does what he does i
sympathize a little bit he's still not
great about it but i understand it i
don't know if i like him but i
understand same thing with a mayor from
jaws
like he's just a [ __ ] you're you're
really pulling together an avengers team
of movie [ __ ] man
i'm like it's like the bureaucrats
and all they're gonna do is like not
really save things but try a little bit
but like he's just like man martin i
just i don't want the summer to go away
these people i love these people they
just need to let some steam off i think
that you're softening his approach
though you're like man martin i don't
want the summer to go away this
[ __ ] was like
amityville is a summertown we need
summer dollars like that guy was born on
front street so business manager he
didn't give a [ __ ] about the people of
amity he just didn't want to catch [ __ ]
when they're like i can't sell my
[ __ ] [ __ ] because nobody's coming the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few there's a couple people who got
to die i don't want to watch jaws from
the [ __ ] pov of the mayor
all i was trying to do
was save a summer for these folks who
rely on their summer dollars to make
their years he's just trying to save his
job he's like if one more person gets
[ __ ] eaten i'm gonna get blamed and
[ __ ] cause the mirror always gets
[ __ ] blamed he's like but i could
push this off on the [ __ ] cop yeah
the new york cop
that's what we don't like who can't swim
yeah
now i kind of want to see the [ __ ]
the mayor version of that movie the pov
of the mayor larry vaughn
um
my kids were on that beach too martin
let me see
character that i
didn't like but now respect
did you ever see uh
uh
last temptation of christ
absolutely christ those jesus characters
[Laughter]
holy unbelievable
magic man who's got a kind heart and a
kind word for everybody
growing up i was like [ __ ]
but now we don't need these many fishes
yeah
now as an adult i'm like you know what
he's all right he's just all right with
me man
um no let's see who did i not like as a
child but like now
my grandfather
i didn't like him when i was a kid he
was so
he was he was the boxer yeah i was like
why'd you [ __ ] give up boxing but now
you understand no i do now i really
understand
i'm like he did it for anal um in in
chat chicken monkey said vernon from the
breakfast club like the principal that's
that that
that would be part of your [ __ ] team
mark's like you know who's misunderstood
the [ __ ] one adult in breakfast club
[ __ ] ed rooney
[Laughter]
that's the other guy that's the
principal of ferris bueller
um
trying to make a difference i'm trying
there's got to be something man
i can share i didn't like them but then
i did grow up and i'm like you know what
i'll still think i still i got a silly
heart a child's heart so i'm still
stuck thinking everybody's impressive
and [ __ ] i haven't reached the uh
that next stage of enlightenment what
are you i uh
i hated the hobbits in lord of the rings
like to the point that i would fast
forward through those parts of the movie
and then fast forward bro yeah well and
then because like frodo gets to the end
i'm like he can't even finish the
[ __ ] job after 14 hours
but then i like
as i'm approaching 40 i re-watch the
extended cuts
there's this scene at the beginning
where they're hanging out in a bar
having a good time
and everybody's having this great time
and then at the end spoilers of the
extended version of return of the king
the like four hobbits are like sitting
there up like dour and everybody else is
having a good time and i was like oh my
god the hobbit's journey is like
growing up and once you grow up you
can't go back to being a kid and i just
wept and now the hobbits are my favorite
part of lord of the rings because of
that one scene that i didn't catch the
first time because now when i watch them
i'm watching like my childhood die on
screen
and and so now as an adult i i love them
whereas as when i was in my early 20s i
hated them because i also love that
there's a version of lord of the rings
that you watch that's like 45 minutes
long
like
there we go aragorn what are you up to
homie
i just think it's incredibly charming
that he [ __ ] found himself watching
the [ __ ] hobbits going like
there but for the grace of god go i
i want to dance on the bed with gandalf
too
perhaps i can escape the eye of sauron
as well
um yeah i don't have any i try to think
if there's some character
johnny lawrence
yeah i mean i guess the whole world
that's a good point the whole yeah i
guess good point my opinion johnny
lawrence has evolved
used to be like what a prick and now
it's just like he's my kind of prick
um good point
what is it
it's true man and they were painted as
the villain i didn't watch the current
season yet of cobra kai has elizabeth
shu come back yet or no
everyone said no but one person said yes
was that elizabeth's shoe
soon
she came back
oh then i did see that
yeah i saw that
no did i no yeah i saw that yeah yeah
yeah now i'm getting her confused with
[ __ ] the boys i'm like wait didn't
she get killed
after expressing some milk for
homelander
i was in the boys cartoon yeah
diabolical diabolical i play booby face
yeah that was my character he took
bought serum and he got
boobs for eyes
to kind of drape in front of his face so
when i was doing the record i was going
like [ __ ] like that
it's fun but they killed my character
off just like that one episode it was
just justin roiland's episode was very
funny spoilers yeah
don't don't hold out hope for booby face
folks
he comes and he goes i've spent my life
holding out hope for boobs
and you'll love this
um yeah i don't i don't think i can't
think of anybody that like other than
johnny lawrence which was voiced about
me rightfully so that's a good answer
yeah i'm in his office i'm right the
ex-principal's show
all the adults all the adults all the
middle managers all the guys just trying
to [ __ ] make the day i mean i
remember as a kid i was not into kermit
what did he do to you
i was just like i don't give a [ __ ] how
easy it is being green like [ __ ] i
was there for fozzie for ralph it's not
easy being white kermit
i was pulling both sides [ __ ] with
[ __ ] kermit
um but as i got older kermit
i like meant more to me than the others
like we're you know [ __ ] pozzi's a
[ __ ] clown
whereas like kermit's got real soul and
[ __ ] responsibilities yeah yeah that's
true as i became
when i was a child i thought like a
child and i appreciated fozzie but when
i became a man i realized we're all
kermit at heart
and i accepted the fact that it's not
easy being green yeah yeah you know who
else i i was a little shitty on as a kid
um
scat man crothers
in uh in the shining
what because what are you hitler who
doesn't [ __ ] like scat man crutches
you like ice cream doc
a lot of ice cream
do you want to see the shining it was
just like
i hated that he was so useless in the
ending
because like he just shows up and gets
axed in the face not in the face in the
chest
my bad i can remember nicholson just
like
and [ __ ] stabs him right with the
[ __ ] oh my god as a child i was like he
was there to help they're [ __ ]
but like which i think was the point of
that scene right but as an older as an
older man
as i'm a preaching approach approaching
approaching scat man cruthers his own
age i'm not that far off from being scat
man's age you're feeling dick hollering
i'm my dick be hollering
and uh and i just i suddenly had all
this empathy for this guy who's like i
was vacationing in miami
and i got a [ __ ] premonition and i
got on a plane i rented a car i got a
[ __ ] snow cat like the lengths he
went to try and save this kid that he
met once yeah suddenly made him a hero
to me even if he gets [ __ ] like you
know stabbed in the chest like a punk
it was still the the the the level of
devotion that he had to danny yeah
suddenly made him a bit more vibrant to
me
i i always liked him and [ __ ] but so he
didn't grow on me like he did for you
i always thought he was cool and uh
i was always sad that he didn't get to
do more in the end
i thought it was cool because it was
like that scene where he's just laying
on his bed and there's a giant velvet
painting of a naked black lady above him
i'm like that's a baller yeah you're
like let's find out his story what are
you doing in miami
he left all that behind to go help a
little kid in the
snow um how come how come he didn't see
the [ __ ]
axe coming you know shawnick didn't show
him that again
yeah
yeah what happens in the book
he he lives in the book right yeah dick
hollering doesn't die in the book that
was in a movie that's my new cannon
what dick hollering doesn't die in the
book
just dick hollering remains alive yes he
lives in you
he lives in all of us kevin you need a
shirt man like one of those like what is
the shirt you wear like uh the
resistance is futile yeah yeah that
[ __ ] yes and you need one that
just says dick hollering lives dot dot
dot in me
[Laughter]
um i think we milked that for all we
could excellent [ __ ] job give it up
for him ladies and gentlemen you win
this sweet poster
you win these sweet 40x tickets
go see the batman and 40x you'll love it
thank you sir thank you care to get wet
um all right jc third and final question
uh
i like this one uh the guy or
gal is jc coombs
jc we got another jc come on give it up
for the second jc
bizarro jc
to jc's enter one jc leaves the jc
variant
listening to the podcast hear my name
said it over and over again this is
really weird i know that must be a weird
experience right
all right so my question is um if wes
anderson was a direct comic book movie
what combo character would fit him best
wow that's anderson wes anderson's doing
a comic book movie
it's got to be twee
it's gotta be
cute
the endless no man that shit's metal
um
gotta give him something that's a little
like
no i mean he would have been ideal for
[ __ ] super pets right
he did that whole island of dogs and
[ __ ] the fantastic mr fox
[Music]
deep thoughts
yeah man i'm trying to think like what
would fit his sensibilities best
probably doom patrol
you know that i i could see him
lining up nicely enough with doom patrol
you
i think the uh
the fantastic case of four adventurers
would be interesting and letting him do
the fantastic four
oh um but i think family works with wes
anderson absolutely i think it's very
like you know royal tenenbaums
um i think the characters are outlandish
enough that you could play
like deadpan with
the things like oh my arm is off again
it's so long look if bill murray gets to
play [ __ ] reed richards
oh my god
that made me so excited
um yeah there's yeah yeah there's that
and uh
and the requisite one black guy plays
the thing
danny glover
i'm getting too rock for this [ __ ]
danny glover
um
what else would wes anderson be good for
astro boy
that's not bad yeah that's true
you can see that
squirrel squirrel girl that could be a
very
wes anderson thing
um
i'm
i keep trying to think of the whimsical
[ __ ] but maybe wes anderson's like i'm
tired of that
he's like i want to do some hardcore
[ __ ] [ __ ] man
you got any comic books where
[ __ ] gets eaten alive i'm like
oh [ __ ] yeah you want one of those and
[ __ ]
um
you know what there was a book i read
years ago
called kingdom of the wicked which was
about toys that came to life which he'd
be amazing for
i'm giving this one so much serious
thought
like i run a studio and i'm like we have
to put wes anderson on a comic book
movie
plastic man that's a good call as well
and woozy woozy winks
i could see that
there was a sandman spin-off there i
think was called like children's crusade
or dead boy detectives or something like
that it was about a pair of kids in a
boarding school one of which is alive
and one of which is dead
um
but i feel like there's a wes anderson
ghost story to be told at some point
and the idea of these two kids rattling
around a giant house and there's a
couple of caretakers and there's the
lawns guy and there's the the headmaster
and there's the chef and some of them
are dead some of them are alive they're
all kind of interacting
i think that that again it's a little
tweet it's a little like organic
marmalade but i think that that that
feels about right i think i got mine
what you got clarion the witch boy
yes
and then you get bill murray to be the
voice of etrigan
and he also plays jason blood
and then he's like could you imagine
bill murray being like gone gone the
form of man and rise the demon
etre again and then he's a you know echo
gun as a cg effect but he's still got
bill murray's voice so it's like
garfield all over it
mondays am i right
um yeah he'd have i think wes anderson
had fun with clarion the witch boy
that's i'm changing my answer it's a
good one yeah now i feel like you got it
i'm going to reach out to wes anderson
be like did you ever read clarion the
witch boy he's like who is this
his kevin smith man he's like oh i love
the king of queens
every time
i told you to stop calling me
um that you gave an answer i gave myself
i give an answer you got some answers
you got a poster you got tickets give it
up for him ladies and gentlemen
jc
the alt jc
pleasure now back to the real jc
how are you captain
good i i think that's the show i think
that's the show that is the [ __ ] well
we'll decide what the [ __ ] show is
but yes you're right we um we didn't
touch on
uh we didn't touch anything we keep our
hands to ourselves on this [ __ ] show
uh alan ladd jr passed who was the guy
who green lights star wars let's talk
about ladder as if we all knew him but
he was known colloquially and the
business's nickname was laddie allen
ladd jr his dad alan ladd senior was a
motion picture actor um very famous one
uh of a generation
of our parents generation my parents
generation i guess maybe not everyone
here
um his son
went into film production
and uh as a studio exec at fox
green let some of your favorite [ __ ]
movies across uh his lifetime but he
wasn't a fox exec or was he for star
wars he was the guy who said yes to star
wars because he loved america he loved
america but was he in charge was he just
a producer or was he at the network he
was
he was the guy at fox who said he was at
fox yeah so he was like i want to meet
with this george lucas kid
i loved american graffiti and he meets
with george lucas and he's like what do
you want to do next and george lucas is
like i want to do star wars
and he's like i want to do dune
i want to do as close to dune as i can
without giving [ __ ] them any dude
money
um and then alan ladd was like i like
this
write it up you got moxie kid yeah he's
the guy without whom [ __ ] star wars
just
lives in george lucas's imagination what
other movies andrew are you back there
i've i thought were you the one that
jumped in with that
did i miss read
keep going
but i thought you were like i thought
you knew much about alan ladd as you did
like north carolina that one time
kentucky kentucky when you came out
you're like that's all [ __ ] the
blood is in the soil
20th century fox you know that
outstanding
um
what else yeah what about how about a
lad company i remember had like the
golden truth like the green tree was a
logo i think they had something to do
with with blade runner i think that had
something to do with alien
i think you're right i think he he he
knew genre i think if we're going to
bring the guy up we should have probably
had his [ __ ] resume handy i mean i
know from star wars us that's true
that's true what you're saying you're
right though we here are here we are in
a uh space-themed bar
um that uh has much in common with a
motion picture that was made many years
ago and that would never have happened
without this guy
so uh he made a lot of great movies but
the one that we're talking about tonight
it's [ __ ] star wars give it up for
the great allen lab jr
um that's uh pretty much all the show we
got for you man we're [ __ ] running on
fumes did you cats like what we did this
evening ladies and gentlemen
are you ready to go home was that one of
those like let us out yeah we're [ __ ]
done
um we're doing this again we're talking
about doing it on march 20th yeah zoom
show a zoom show i will be live at smod
castle but you guys will be zooming in
you're not doing it live from the bar i
mean we
i don't we could
try it it'd be amazing amazing to have
[ __ ] like two live audiences across
the [ __ ] country and [ __ ] yeah let's
try it
that'd be nuts let's go for it so
tickets on sale you'll probably put them
up tonight tickets uh will be on sale uh
for the smart castle half of the show
and jc is gonna put up tickets for the
uh scum and villainy cantina part of the
show and we'll [ __ ] zoom at each
other oh with with [ __ ] separate
audiences yeah how [ __ ] dope is that
it'll be like the oscars and [ __ ]
but you know watchable yes and we'll
we'll talk about all the categories yeah
we'll do all the categories and [ __ ]
um i enjoy doing the show and uh we
don't get to do the show uh without uh
folks being interested in the show for
so for the folks at home and
particularly for the folks here in the
scum and villainy cantina live in our
audience thank you for coming out and
supporting fat man beyond thank you for
turning on your [ __ ] youtube channel
and watching us and [ __ ] like that
because that's how you work youtube
by doing that
we don't get to do the show uh without a
home and our home is right here this
coming villainy cantina and that here
this bar is owned uh uh proprietor of
this here bar is uh the one and only jc
give it up for banff man jc
all these fine people here and mark as
well as you can see three [ __ ] drinks
to the wind and [ __ ] like that
um are are
over served in the best possible way
uh give it up for the staff here it's
coming villainy cantina ladies and
gentlemen keeping them lubricated
one last thing before we run on march
29th we're having a book signing here at
scum and villainy for my own graphic
novel here called a door in the distance
so
if you come down 7pm that day you can
buy a book i'll tag it nice
kevin will be here and we'll do a little
q a behind the bar but come and have fun
drink the drinks get a book what day is
it tuesday the 29th marketing calendars
kids tuesday the 29th right here
right here right here that's common
villain
um if you're not doing anything on
saturday night kids i'm doing hollywood
babylon over at flappers comedy club uh
in burbank with ralph garman the last
few shows have been wonderful come on
out and [ __ ] join us tickets are at
seasmod.com
uh we don't get to do this here show
without the guy standing to my left give
it up for the marvelous mark bernard
ladies and gentlemen
and that my friends is fat man beyond
for this week i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernard tune in next time same fat time
same fat channels podcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith and jeff's kiss
ladies and gentlemen wow
rip quick quick
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam bob get old off kevin smith